please come in you're welcome to come
and take a seat
you're welcome as chair of division one
of the house finance committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session pertaining to
division budget matters
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and in public and the public has access
to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should email
lba underscore fiscal at
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes taken during
this meeting will be done by roll call
we are forced to start every meeting
with a rogue with a roll call
and people have to state where they are
so here in room 202 in the lob
i have to my left vice chairman tracy
emmerich
to my right representative
robert tuberge who is our clerk to his
right
representative jerry griffin
representative peter leishman had to go
to
concord orthopedics this morning he had
a slight skein accident
had an x-ray and they found a wee tiny
fracture so he will be along later
representative walls are you online
represents she is not representative
hatch
okay it's just us we're going to start
the meeting at nine o'clock
with
chairman ken weiler who is here to talk
about house bill 2
section 26
76 thank you ken and
mr hoffman has the testimony ken
presented to
full finance during the public hearing
on his bill which has been
amended and he also has proposed
language for amendment 2
which is not yet an amendment but he is
going to talk about that
and then at 9 10 we will be starting
with the judicial branch ken welcome and
thank you for joining us here please
turn your microphone on
and run us through your proposed
amendment
thank you good morning madam chair
members of the committee
i'm ken weiler representative from
rockingham 13.
about 10 years ago i chaired the third
investigative committee on the frm
scandal
the committee report found both the
banking department and the attorney
general's office had lied to the public
and then covered up the lies the
investors who in their due diligence
called those two agencies were told
that the frm mortgage company was one of
the safest banks around
banking had 79 findings against frm at
that time
the ag consumer bureau also gave advice
that the frm had no problems
even though they were aware of the
banking problems and were investigating
the principal officer
farah for fraud it was disclosed that
the banking commissioner's brothers
were some of the first investors in frm
agency and were enjoying 15
returns on their money the commission is
seemingly stalled until his family got
their money out
when the evidence was too great to be
ignored the commissioner went into the
frm office
and looked into a file and found one
document that he claimed showed that the
matter was under securities bureau
then he walked out and left the door
open the securities bureau comes under
the secretary of state's office and some
testimony
said the ag and banking were trying to
shift the blame
to protect governor lynch the director
of securities mark connelly wrote a book
titled
cover-up explaining the scam and its
aftermath
the second investigation
a lawyer and he put all 200 interviewees
on
interviewees under oath when we compared
the assistant
a.g testimony under oath with what he
said to my committee it was entirely
different
there have been previous attempts to
right this wrong as you can see from the
legislation from 2013
but attempts to put the money in the
bill always saw it later removed
excuse me these fund sources are not
general funds and are restricted
funds the rest of the amendment enables
the use
please see that help see justice is done
moving to my amendment which hasn't been
put in a formal thing yet it starts with
number 76 which reads appropriation
uh frm victims contribution recovery
fund for the purpose of awarding
assistance to victims
of the frm fraud there is hereby
appropriated
the sum of five million dollars for the
fiscal year ending june 30th 2022
and the sum of five million for the
fiscal year ending june 30th 2023
to the frm victims contribution recovery
fund established in rsa
359 p colon 2.
now when i first looked at this in the
first version
the draft version of hb2 it read 5
million
but then when i saw the later version it
was changed to like half a million
and i saw no had no explanation why
but i know that if you put 10 million in
there someone's going to grab it because
they think it's coming out of general
fund
so i've amended rsa 359 p2
as you can see uh where this was it this
has been in law since 2013
and i've changed some of the language
there so
at one point it said they would have to
go out and recruit a lawyer that would
work for 10
of the of the money raised
without naming a uh
an appropriation this one says for the
fiscal year ending june 30th 2022 the
fund shall draw
on the investors education fund in the
bureau of securities regulation
one million dollars plus from the
department of justice consumer
protection escrow account
four million dollars for the fiscal year
ending june 30th we
draw from those same uh funds again
these withdrawals shall continue until
the frm victims contribution recovery
fund achieves a balance of 10 million
dollars
in the event the funds are not available
any of the aforementioned fiscal years
to achieve the 10 million dollars
then the fund shall continue to draw
from those sources until 10 million
is achieved the same sources shall be
drawn on to fund the employees
that the director shall appoint to serve
on the attorney administrator in
359 p4 which have also changed the
language a bit so that'll work
uh it used to say the director shall
hire slash a point now if we
delete slash appoint a private and put
an attorney or administrator who shall
take out collect gifts and contributions
and review applications for assistance
submitted pursuant to this chapter
turn it over make awards of assistance
in accordance with the procedures of
this chapter and report annually to the
director
commencing on february 1st 2022 and each
february first thereafter
the director shall negotiate the
attorney or administrative salary and
benefit level in accordance with similar
levels within the department
and then we move on to cha make some
slight changes to
rsa 7 colon 6f i have
consulted with both secretary of state
bill gartner
these funds are not to be used except
for investor education but he approved
them
to be in in this fund and also i've
talked with
mc gordon mcdonald when he was the
attorney general
he said there's about 9 million a year
comes in through this
investor or it's let's see what the
title of it is
the consumer protection escrow account
and it cannot exceed five million they
usually use it within house to to pay
for the attorneys that are working in
consumer protection
so um i changed that so that
there won't be any question when the
money comes out of that fund
that it that it is able to be taken out
so
this this amendment involves a few
sections of law
and i'm happy to answer any question ken
thank you very much for coming i
am as representative wyler knows getting
a
draft amendment that the committee will
look at later
however i wanted to have
any committee member have a chance to
ask a question about the funding
i know some people are not in favor of
this we will be
discussing those kinds of items when we
have an actual
committee hearing and i can say that
representative walls has joined us and i
sure she's at home and maybe her
daughter and
husband are around or maybe she but
she's alone in her room so i can see her
on the screen now good morning
representative walls and welcome
good morning i'm sorry i was a couple of
minutes late no problem
engaged in other work believe it or not
i can't believe it
do you have any questions just about the
funding mechanism because while ken
is here he can explain that i cannot
very well and we will have
an amendment as i said to discuss the
pros and cons of his proposal
i actually think he's done a good job of
explaining the funding mechanism i do
understand it and i thank him for his
clarity
okay chairman weiler i i really
appreciate you spending the first 10
minutes
with us this morning thank you for
coming thank you for listening and i
look forward to having this amendment
into hb2 because this has been a long
time coming and i hope to find a way to
take care of it thank you very much
[Music]
so saying that we now have the judicial
branch
with with us and i have
supreme court justice gordon mcdonald
who is going to come forward
and we're going to bring up a chair i
think mr keating are you going to sit
with him or is donna going to sit with
him or are you going to rotate chairs
okay well you can do whatever you want
we also have in the room
justice fred king it's always good to
see you sir so thank you for coming
and i think on the wire let me see i
talked to tina yesterday
and i'm about to move her over into zoom
oh absolutely chris
please distribute anything you have
um sir anybody beside
hi tina anybody besides tina you want
moved over
gordon
okay all right so a few little ground
rules we
you're happily in a room where
we have joined the herd via either
vaccine or tracy's method was having
covered in recovering so
when we all move he has the deep move
because he took the hard route and the
rest of us kind of squeak in soprano
but it is good for us to have be started
to be crossed into a
situation where covet is endemic and not
pandemic
you are welcome the microphone you have
to push it forward you'll have a real
little red light we do have a little
difficulty with people at home hearing
so
i ask you to be kind of pulling my
mic close even here and we try to make
everybody be able to hear
so let me say budget presentation is
yours
and jane young is paying me with candy
bars to ask you tough questions because
you left her alone with the ag's budget
she did a great job by the way
um well good morning madam chair members
of division one i
i heard my own account of that your
session together i
heard something about lambs and
slaughter and
i thought they did a good job they
needed to send us a crosswalk which they
did
and they found an errata sheet which
with budget errors
which we approved yesterday so those
have been fixed
so i didn't think they were slaughtered
or lambs but it was her first time and
she was like couldn't he have waited
another week and i said
i will take that up with him
well for better or worse i'm appearing
before you in
in a different role and it is truly an
honor to be before division one
it's in an enormous honor to be here as
the chief justice of the supreme court
and i thank division members for their
time uh with me obviously i'll state for
the record our
superior court chief justice tina nado
circuit court administrative judge david
king and
donna raymond our physical manager and
chris keating who is the director of the
administrative office of the courts
every day judges of our state work
diligently to discharge their duties
and meet the fundamental ideals set
forth in our bill of rights part 1
article 35
that is the right of every citizen to be
tried by judges
as impartial as the lot of humanity will
permit
the function of the judicial branch is
absolutely essential to our democracy
and it literally touches the lives of
each
one of our citizens and the people of
new hampshire
in one way or another the work of the
courts affects us
all from the well over 100 000 cases
filed every year in our circuit courts
dealing with
immediate issues of great concern to the
litigants involving family law
small claims landlord-tenant issues
probate issues
to important questions of law which are
decided by
our supreme court and are binding and
affect us
all in the very short time i have been
chief justice and phantom chair it has
been less than a week so
yeah we heard about that from the doj
um i've seen the work of our judges
and i've seen the incredible work by
those who support them throughout the
judicial branch
and we all benefit from very experienced
leadership of both our trial courts
justice nato and judge king i did not
participate in the development of the
budget
submission that's before division one
but i am pleased to be here and support
in support of it and offer my
perspectives and my viewpoint on it
are the judicial branches unique rsa
excuse me nine colon 4a provides that a
separate branch
as a separate branch of government the
judicial branch submits its budget
along with other executive along with
executive branch agency budgets however
the governor
will not may not change the budget
submitted he may give
comments and there were no comments
associated with the judicial branch's
submission this year
we have uh slides for
division members and uh
madam chair i circulated a letter last
night we brought hard copies
with us this morning answering the
divisions questions and the chairs
questions
trust me by last night i didn't see it
i'm only getting a minor
two to three thousand emails a day about
what we're doing in the budget
don't cut this cut them no don't cut me
cut them
back and forth i i i can appreciate that
um so let me let me touch on a few
highlights and give an overview of the
judicial branch for the benefit of
division members and then turn it over
to donna for a more detailed discussion
on our submission
if if you have your slides the slides
before you let me
let me talk about two basic principles
underlying the judicial branch
budget slide 14.
the judicial branch budget is primarily
generally funded and as you will see for
uh fiscal 22 and 23 it's
basically 94 next principle
is the next slide which is
about 74 of the branches budget
is personnel related and i know uh
division members know the consequences
and the and the implications of that
slide 20
gives you a snapshot of the submission
year over year change over uh fy 21
adjusted authorized is 4.4
for uh fy 22 say fiscal year 22 and then
uh 4.1 percent for state year fiscal
year
23. and then slide
21 gives you an overview
of the new positions and other
non-personnel
items above baseline that we are
requesting
and as you will see we have uh
five new positions and
uh per diem increase for our court
securities officers
please tell me what an access to justice
navigator program position does
access to justice navigators or a
recommendation
that came through the supreme court's
commission on access to justice
they will serve in the circuit court
to help guide litigants
through the landlord tenant dockett
initially the landlord tenant docket
is predominated as are most
cases in the circuit court by
self-represented litigants
the landlord tenant docket is very
challenging
for two reasons one is it is statute
based
and deadline driven and the second is
because of the pandemic
there will be a wave of landlord-tenant
cases coming
the idea of court navigators are to
assist
self-represented litigants
in issues relating to
filling out the forms negotiating
uh settlements keeping an eye
on critical deadlines
and generally helping to navigate what
can be a
very foreign and intimidating process
the business proposition madam chair for
the navigators
is to relieve already very
very challenged judge
time strain judge time and court
resource
time staff time and
in sort of divert if you will
questions relating to the substance of
this docket
to the navigator program
the two positions before you and the
appropriation that goes with it
will help leverage a federal grant in
the amount of a hundred thousand dollars
and they the the idea is for these
two positions to to recruit
train and staff
a core of volunteers who will help with
this function
so are these positions federally funded
or generally funded no these are the
positions before you are generally
funded
okay and on slide 21
yep are all of those items in your
budget as presented
yes
i'd now like to give a brief overview of
the judicial
branch slightly as to what slide number
what slide three please slide three yep
[Music]
and again i know division the division
is familiar with the judicial branch but
just to
sort of get everyone on the same page
about what we are and what we do
and what we're comprised of there is one
appellate court in our state the supreme
court
in two trial courts the superior court
and the circuit court
and the office the administrative office
of the court
assists all courts with the
administrative responsibilities in
running the judicial branch
slide four
this is the organizational chart for the
judicial branch
the supreme court has five justices
no vacancies at this time
the superior court is our court of
general trial jurisdiction there are 22
full-time judges funded
three vacancies so 19
judges currently serving the circuit
court
is comprised of three divisions the
district division
the family division and the probate
division
35 judges are funded
45 are actually authorized under statute
and 30 of those positions are filled
so there are currently five vacancies so
so let me go back to
i don't know page 20 or 21 but but
whatever we looked at
you said 35 full-time judges are
authorized you added to circuit court
so did you fund two more out of the 45
so you now have 37
that's exactly right okay thank you
uh slot slide five please a little
deeper dive on the supreme court five
justices uh the supreme court hears
appeals from all levels of court
mandatory jurisdiction in most civil and
criminal and juvenile cases
in discretionary jurisdiction with
respect to administ appeals from
administrative agencies
uh the supreme court issues advisory
opinions requested by the legislative
and executive branches
and it addresses questions certified
by the federal court
the next slide the supreme court
also has administrative responsibilities
as
the head of the judicial branch
the chief justice serves as the
administrative head of all courts
we appoint administrative judges and we
receive
recommendations from an administrative
council which is led
comprised of the leaders of those courts
we oversee the attorney discipline
system we oversee the judicial conduct
system
there is an advisory committee on rules
for judicial branch rules
and we oversee bar admissions
next slide the superior court again
uh as we as i mentioned 22 judges funded
19 currently serving
there are also two senior active
judges and those judges are below the
constitutional age of 70
and they are therefore permitted
constitutionally to sit
and they are used to fill in gaps
the superior court conducts jury trials
it has a broad civil jurisdiction for
basically any dispute over 1500
dollars and then criminal jurisdiction
over all felonies there are 11
courthouses statewide one in every
county two
in hillsborough and the superior court
operates and conducts the
drug court which has locations in 10
locations statewide
next slide no there aren't 10 drug
courts are there
there are tina i thought you said one
county didn't want to have a drug court
there are two locations in hillsborough
north oh that's right
and then how can i forget i live in
hillsboro we have double the expense two
courthouses okay more coffee
thank you yes represent everett
uh i'm just curious how are the drug
courts working out
because we're going to have a chance to
ask tina about that she's got a proposal
for us in fact so
here that'll come up thank you madam
chair
uh slide nine please uh again the
circuit court has three divisions one is
the district division
it has jurisdiction over civil claims
small small claims mostly run through
the district division
landlord tenant as i discussed
class a and b misdemeanors
violation and level offenses traffic
offenses
and then domestic violence jurisdiction
that it shares with the family division
the probate division is
the successor to the probate courts it
has jurisdiction established under rsa
chapter 547 and it handles
everything from adoptions to wills and
estates trusts
involuntary admissions and has equity
jurisdiction next the family division
the third division of the circuit court
handles
marital matters custody and support
juvenile matters
adoptions uh termination of parental
rights
and guardianship issues uh so that's an
overview of the court system and now
madam sheriff
the commission if the division is
amenable to it i'd like to turn it over
to donna raymond to give an overview
of some of the budget details we'll be
happy to take it from
donna but donna give me just a second
yesterday congress passed the covet
relief bill
and i fully expect that president biden
will sign it
i'm on the executive council
state reps take care of their county
budgets as well
we didn't have enough to do so i'm on
the executive committee in hillsborough
county
hillsborough county alone is is
projected to get and this is online so
this is not
news you can't read if you haven't been
you know that on the government website
they've got this hillsborough county is
projected to
get an additional 80 million dollars the
formula is something like
of that 80 million 70 you'll only get 75
percent
of whatever your operating budget was
but it's one-time money every county is
getting it
it's one-time money to be spent on
infrastructure
so let me remind you our courts are in
our county systems
do you have buildings that have some
infrastructure needs that don't get
budgeted
i highly advise you to work with all of
the counties
uh the city of manchester alone
is expected to get 44 million dollars
so i don't know whether parking issues
at one of your things someplace
let me put that in your ear you're going
to pass here but we've got this other
thing coming up
according to what is online you will be
able to spend that money through
2024. so i've just been reading the
federal website because
obviously i don't have enough to do here
clearly i don't have enough to do with
the budget so
but you guys this impacts you in every
county and i wanted to mention
it to you this morning so you start
thinking about it start working with
your county delegations
outside the budget donna thank you for
letting me have that short recess please
continue
with what we're really here to do
so good morning so um chief justice
gordon mcdonald already took you through
some of the slides
mary beth can you hear her yeah
all right um with some of the slides
regarding the budget overview
um so i don't know that i really need to
repeat any of that no
don't repeat with each other we'll go
right into the gory detail
yep gory details where we want to be all
right
that will take us to slide
27 slide 20 in your pocket
and the budget for you um uh starts on
page 196
for the judicial branch
so i thought it would be helpful um if i
provided just an explanation
of what is in some of our expense class
lines because they can be a little bit
different sometimes in the executive
branch agency so hopefully this will be
helpful to you
after this meeting as you read through
our budget again to understand
what some of those class lines actually
are so now i will
go line by line through the budget with
an explanation
of each class line yep
so we're starting with 1880 which is the
supreme superior
and the administrative office of the
courts are all budgeted in this
accounting unit
class 10 is where our clerical staff
are budgeted in for full time and
the amounts that you see in 22 and 23
and i'm sure you've heard this so many
times
uh fiscal year 23 has 27 27th pay period
oh yeah
which you know probably in your sleep
but yes that will be responsible for
some of those increases um
so what we see here is the increase is
the net impact of position
adjustments so throughout the course of
fiscal year 20 and 21 we have
adjusted positions such that it netted
out to two full-time positions
and we are also asking for a full-time
land one specialist in our it department
because of all the technology that is
being used now in the courts
the i.t department really feels that
being able to support
uh courts across the state
is we just don't have the resources in
order to do that adequately with the
staff they have so they're requesting
one more
land specialist to make
to help people in a more timely manner
class
11 personal services unclassified is
where the full-time judges in both the
supreme and the superior
port are budgeted you see it actually a
reduction of eighteen hundred dollars
the judge's salaries have had no
increase so it is actually due to
a change in the membership of those
judges and they have different longevity
amounts
newer ones coming in don't have as much
longevity as ones who have
retired and that's why you see a
decrease in that line
class excuse me class 12
personal services unclassified is where
we budget for our senior active status
judges and again those are the ones who
have not attained the age of 70 but
continue to serve they do so on a per
diem basis
and i've tried to increase that a little
bit
to reflect what i project will be the
need
for senior active status judges in the
superior court the supreme court does
not have them
and we're also anticipating some backlog
that may need to be um
addressed in 22 as well so i
put a little bit more in just to cover
that
class 18 is overtime and again i'm just
trying to
increase that budget a little bit to
anticipate overtime needs to deal with
the backlog in the courts
class 20 is current expense and i've
adjusted those numbers a bit to better
reflect
actuals
for 20 in that we saw in fiscal year
and i'm projecting fiscal year 2021 to
be 700 000
um i mean we're three-quarters into the
fiscal year so i have a better sense of
where our expenses are heading
so i increased it a little bit over and
above that for
22 and 23. class 22
is our rents and leases and the
increases there reflect
an increase in our rental space at one
granite place
and we also are now leasing our
multi-function copiers they're no longer
just copiers they they scan they
you can print you can send things to
other people through them i believe
and we went to a model instead of
purchasing them we now lease them
because the technology keeps changing
and we just cannot keep up with it it
doesn't make sense to actually purchase
these things and deal with ever-changing
technology so
we went to a leasing model and what
we've done in 22 is we've added
15 more leases to address other courts
whose copiers are going to be at end of
life
and then in fiscal year 23 we've added
an additional
eight leases for those courts that whose
copiers are going to be at end of life
that should complete the leasing for all
of our courts at that point
i think you're going to be entering into
a three-year leasing contract fairly
soon our leases
are expiring and so those numbers should
stabilize
class 24 is maintenance other than
buildings and grounds
and that's maintenance for the vehicles
that we own
other office maintenance that we may
have
and i've increased that a little bit one
of the problems with this is can be a
little unpredictable when a part goes on
a car
we need that vehicle in operation so we
have to fix it so
we also have a snowblower at the supreme
court those types of things
it's all these little things that will
sometimes break down that we need to
make sure we have the funding for to
keep these things
operational class 26 is organ
organizational dues excuse me
the vast bulk of that is our dues
payment to the national center for state
courts
we have also added seven thousand
dollars in each of fiscal year 22 and 23
for a contract with the national center
for state courts for a language
for a language access and that is uh
geared toward making um
non-english-speaking people
um have more access to the court system
class 27 is transfers to department of
information technology
that's probably going to go up a little
bit donna we discovered that
doit failed to put cyber security
insurance in their class 27 and instead
they budgeted it straight in
das which was fine but did for 600 000
das had to cut several staff in order to
cover that
so that's now going to be distributed
out across every agency it's going to be
minor but you will see an errata sheet
and just so you know when you get it you
won't have to come back i just want to
let you know
okay it may not impact us you see the
number is 80
now i don't know it won't impact you
it's going to be a slight increase so
when you guys look at your budget and
think what the heck happened
it's just being taken care of because
everybody does need the cyber security
insurance i mean we can't build that
okay yeah we have our own cyber security
yeah program
okay you're actually covered by this
insurance as well you have your own
program but this insurance i understand
helps you clean up uh protect you if you
get sued
after something there is a break
whatever every agency is covered so
when you see a little bit of an increase
i just want you to know why
okay thank you class 30 equipment
the increase there is in fiscal year 22
and that is excuse me to provide
new furniture for belknap superior court
and also a little bit for video
conferencing equipment video
conferencing equipment
reaches end of life as well and so we
typically budget
for one courthouse to have its video
conferencing equipment
renewed each fiscal year
class 38 technology software that is for
uh the law library it utilizes two
software applications
it provides electronic access and
cataloging services
and those are their contracts and they
go up every year
the law library has tried to mitigate
those increases as much as it can
by doing a longer term contract so i
think they try to negotiate three-year
contracts at this point the rates get a
little bit lower but
despite that those rates are not fixed
for those three years they still
continue to go up each year built
you know in in the contract itself
class 39 excuse me telecommunications
that right now and we'll see what comes
with additional funding um
we are incurring approximately twelve
thousand dollars a month in additional
telecom for our open voice so the
circuit court primarily
is conducting hearings remotely so
what's happening is people are calling
in
and every person who calls in is charged
the same amount so it sounds like it's a
really great rate but when you have 10
or 12 people on that call
for every minute they're on there it
really racks up so
the baseline cost is about 9 500 but the
the tax on that has increased
significantly it
increases every quarter it's now 31.8
percent of it so that's why
the cost itself is quite high uh prior
to
january one we were actually charging
that to some cares act funding that we
were able to receive from gopher
but i was instructed that we could not
use any surplus that we had
in that funding after december 30. so
i just anticipated i think all the cares
funny had to be spent by that
time or else i thought the feds extended
it but i
no oh all right but anyways and who
knows what you're getting in the latest
thing i mean i'm just trying to read the
latest bill that passed
okay yeah we won't we won't talk about
that
all right so hopefully that will not
come to
reality in terms of hitting our general
fund budget but the courts do need to
continue to operate and
process the the backflow of cases as
well so
that's why we put it in there indirect
costs
again that is just um a calculation of
where we will pay the indirect costs
that are associated with any federal
grants that we work on the number is
small we don't have a lot of federal
grants
but our accounting unit 1880 is where we
have our administrative costs budgeted
and that's where we post
that expense
class 46 consultants we've added
a little bit of money seventy thousand
dollars for an it consultant for
software integration
uh ninety seven thousand for network for
a network
security consultant and fifty thousand
dollars
for mitigation of documents
in the supreme court that are uh molding
and
need to be treated
what's new in there the 70 000 is the um
net impact of hiring network security
consultant
um our it team recognized that we were
our network was vulnerable
and so we are really shoring that up we
hire a consultant who comes in and does
audits
i think once a quarter and we are
continually improving
to make sure that our data and our
information on our networks is protected
40 class 48 contractual maintenance
buildings and grounds
donna why don't you just hit the ones
that have an increase
okay or rather even a significant can
increase
plus 49 that's um bureau of facilities
yeah um
that number comes from them but that is
what they estimate before our buildings
um
let's see class 50 goes down for example
so
that's because we converted part-time
positions to full-time so you'll see
reduction there
that is a big reduction for the number
of part-time people one of them was the
labor grade 60 step nine they were very
high that's why you see that number so
big for the number of
part-time reductions um benefits
it follows the salaries and also our
judicial so not only
is nhrs retirement in that benefits line
but also judicial retirement plan
benefits for our judges
is in that line it increased excuse me
from 69.4
in 20 and 21 to 77.6
and 22.23 and that is based on an
actuarial analysis to project
what contribution would need to be made
in order to fund that
does anyone have any other questions on
accounting unit 1880 a lot of those
other ones are reductions you see a 200
000 reduction in class 73 grants that is
drug court that is sullivan county not
participating in our drug court program
so
we remove the funding for that
any other questions on accounting unit
1880 otherwise i will continue i don't
see anybody has any questions at the
moment so we'll i will
come on flip the page okay
the next accounting unit excuse me is
1995 mediation and arbitration funds
and this program funds paid mediation
and arbitration
and supports operation of the program we
have one
uh clerical staff one full-time person
and this uses no general funds no
general funds at all no all right
it's yeah right okay it's a surcharge
from
various filings that people do but then
we get to
judge king's area and now we're going to
use general funds
what's up when he says
so moving on to um accounting unit 8670
circuit court
again we see an impact from the position
adjustments i don't know if you've had a
chance to read the letter but
the circuit court throughout fiscal year
20 and 21 has been
um carefully managing its positions but
um
changing some part-time positions to
full-time positions you have
judge king don't you have a section in
hb2
on this am i
wait a minute sometimes i have
nightmares in the middle of the night
i'm like
i think you do
section 16 is that you
section 16 which is on
page eight
well starts at the bottom of page eight
so of course the verb reaches on page
nine so
says for the biennium ending june 30th
2023 the number of judges serving on
oh this is superior court i'm sorry this
is tina's
never mind my mistake judge king will
get tina when she gets
when she gets there so she can talk to
that
okay please continue yes and class 10 is
the clerical
staff class 11 excuse me are
full-time judges and per diem judges
and this is the net impact of adding
two additional full-time circuit court
judges
again from our current staffing of 35 to
as we discussed and also the
impact of longevity and
reduced and adjusted for the per diem
judges who also are funded out of this
class line
uh cost 12 has no variance to it
class 16 is where we budget for the
marital masters they have different
longevities
now they've got an additional 300 in
each year
um the the next large line
would be class 60 benefits and again
it follows salary and the jr the
judicial retirement plan rate increase
from 69.4 to 77.6
and uh interpreter services i put extra
money in there we never seem to have
enough
we never budgeted enough money for our
interpreter services costs i think
part of it is the the services
the cost of it increases as well and the
number of people probably needing
the service anyone have any other
questions
on circuit court budget seeing none
we're going to
again flip the page
the next um accounting unit is
accounting unit 1736 which is the i.t
dedicated fund which i think you are
well acquainted with and i just wanted
to note how
thankful and appreciative we are of the
legislature
funding our operations in fiscal year 20
and 21
general fund appropriation it has been
so helpful to us
well as i as i've said a number of times
this was not
intended to fund everything but we were
at a point where
at the time a former chief justice
would take all the computer money in
this
in your branch and turn it into books or
something
and we wanted to see you guys modernized
and you have so it's
it's well worth the expense to bring
ease to some of the residents
yes so the way i budget for
this line is class 37 technology
hardware
we use for the generally funded portion
of that budget
and class 38 is the truly dedicated
portion of that budget each year we file
an annual report of the it dedicated
funds which gives a much more
detailed explanation of how we use those
funds i read that
yep
and the next accounting unit is court
security
and there aren't too many uh big changes
there but i do want to point out with
the courts
closed for so long how has that
impacted what you're actually paying out
of your adjusted authorized budget
well i'd like to say the courts were
never really closed we
limited access by the public in person
but we continue to operate on obviously
switching to
remote methods to do that we have seen
reductions in certain areas of our
budget obviously in jury trials
we've seen it so that's what we pay to
our jurors to show up
for um jury duty that has seen a big
decrease some we've seen decreases in
travel
um so it has it has impacted our budget
favorably
in that regard only
representative
uh robert mr keating you can
unfortunately not speak from there you
do not have a microphone
you can move up here and share the
microphone
um you can use
representative leishman's microphone you
have to turn on thank you
we aren't we aren't miked for every seat
in the room i apologize but we've done
the best we can
we have this wonderful equipment that
cleans the air five times an hour
one up here and one back there so we
feel really
nice and safe in here besides the fact
we've all been
getting our vaccine so yes thank you now
that you have a mic
i just wanted to add that the courts
have been
open this entire time and judge king had
to close
franklin for a day just because we ran
out of staff
because of a bit of a covet scare but
they've been open and in fact the court
security officers
have really stepped up during the
pandemic
and have done yeoman's work greeting
people at the front doors
and carrying out the kind of screening
activities
that are happening in this building and
engaging with people coming into the
courthouse taking our temperatures when
these
facts prove that you don't necessarily
run a fever when you have the disease
yeah i
i think that's a wonderful waste of man
time
well and when people come in scientific
facts
right sorry madam chair but when people
come in
needing to address their legal issues um
we have the court security officers out
front sorting through that and deciding
who can come through
and who can be taken care of just at the
front there and so they're faring papers
back and forth
and not bringing people right into the
court
uh clerks area or the courtroom and then
we're operating hearings on a daily
basis and
and actually holding in-person hearings
and so
we've been we've been open and
security's been provided
during that whole time so that's why our
expenditures have been high
through the period okay thank you
this budget also reflects a recommended
10 increase in the per diem rate of pay
for our court security officers and
concurrently
for sheriff's bailiffs in our superior
courts
is that part of a contract
it is not in the collect is a
recommendation right now i do not
believe it's in the collective
bargaining
agreement they are negotiating with the
teamsters now are they not
but it's not contractual
i don't know how that language is going
to be worded
yeah but you've got a budget for current
law you can't budget for what you might
have
the i think the only stipulation
uh is for the sheriffs which says in
chapter law
that they shall receive the same rate of
pay as our court security officers but
our court security officer's rate of pay
is negotiated
through our collective bargaining so is
the question is and i think it's yes or
no
is this above what is in your current
contract
yes yes can you please
get me a figure for how much above it is
beyond your current contract
yes i know you don't have it with you
but you can get it send it to
mr hoffman down at lba please and with
copy to me
thank you
and then the last line would be the
sheriff's reimbursement which we just
talked about
which also reflects that
and then we have judicial conduct
committee
which has been active this year yes
unfortunately unfortunately
yeah um so i work with
um bob middleholzer who is the executive
secretary and general counsel
it's pretty much flat funded yep for the
most yeah
it really is and
we have court accounting unit 2722 the
court improvement project
which again is representative of our
federal
grants that we have i will note that we
are
starting to pursue more actively federal
funding
um because we are concerned that there
may be federal funds that we're leaving
on the table
so we're we're having internal
discussions about that and what it may
take to
operate more grant programs within the
organization that has
not been our focus in the past and we
want to make sure that if we do
proceed down this path that we not only
write
good grants but that we are also
managing
any funding that we do receive there are
lots of terms and conditions that you
have to meet the requirements yeah
i think that's a good idea um
i think we support that now i want to
tina if you can unmute yourself and i
told
tracy he had a question you would answer
it but i also know you
have something you want to talk about
with drug court and some of the drug
court money so
if you can speak to us about that sure
thank you very much madam chair and i
appreciate the ability to appear
remotely
i wish i could see you all in person but
that will come soon um i'll just give
you a quick thumbnail on the drug courts
are doing well
we have served 971 participants since
you
authorized statewide funding 345 of them
have graduated and 314 are still in a
certain phases of the
of the program you know it takes between
one and two years to complete
we have actually started working on a
recidivism study so we are we were able
to obtain
a statewide database system so that all
the courts are collecting the same data
once we have all that information from
2016 on migrated we'll be able to pick a
comparison group and do a recidivism
study so
things are going well the teams are
getting great training
and they are following best practices
which was our goal we did have a
national association
come in and do a research project to
make sure they were following
evidence-based practices and we made
adjustments in certain courts that
needed
some improvements here and there so
that's just sort of the overall i'm
happy
even i know you have a lot to get
through today so if anyone has any
questions
later or offline i'm happy to go into
more detail
the one issue that we discussed amongst
ourselves it was actually
prompted by chief justice mcdonald got
me thinking a little bit more about
how we should take this step as you
heard from donna
the sullivan county has decided they
don't want to operate a drug court
we've worked with them we've tried to
encourage them we've
met with the county attorney there and
we certainly don't want to force it on
anyone
and and so we figured we would give that
some time it's been since 2016
and we thought maybe one approach would
be
to use that money somehow and i would i
would want your input on that
representative ober
to either spread it out amongst the
other counties or to focus that money on
the smaller counties because they have a
smaller amount of money
but somehow to improve the programming
in other counties we have not
seen an increase in funding for the drug
courts since
you first authorized it and not even a
cost of living increase
so that was just one thought but i'm
happy to talk about other ideas you
might have
and happy to answer any questions
representative walsh you have your hand
up
i do thank you so tina i think you were
on the committee with me that looked at
expanding the drug courts to basically
include mental health courts
and i while i've not followed as closely
as i should i know that bill is moving
through the house
but my finance question to you is if
that bill
passes do you need additional funding to
implement that or
is the systems you've got in place
adequate
so the bill that is going through the
house i think there may be a
recommendation
for it to be an expedient to legislate
was simply to
have the chief justice of the supreme
court provide a report that issues
what kind of standards should we follow
for mental health courts
and um even if it doesn't pass we are
working on creating some standards so
before
we would even bridge that question about
funding but certainly
um there are i think about 16 mental
health courts operating through the
circuit court right now there are
maybe two or three programs in superior
court
their their focus is a little different
than the drug court
so the idea would be to have a
coordinator that would work with our
overall
office to um coordinate with the mental
health courts
certainly people in drug court have
mental health issues and they are
treated at the same time
and the circuit court programs focus
mostly on people with
that have a major their their major
issue is significant mental health
issues
and they continually get rearrested for
those kind of low-level crimes so
i think the first step is develop
standards and then what kind of funding
we would need would be
much farther down the road do you have a
follow-up mary beth
i don't thank you for that because i
just wondered how it
impacted you financially that clarifies
it thank you very much
and by the way let me say i didn't
realize the bill was itl apparently in
committee i'm sorry to hear that
well it was that that's the
recommendation i think it was a very
close call so we'll see what happens on
the house floor but
i can assure you that judge king and i
are are going to work on standards
anyway
it's good to hear that thank you well if
the bill was
for working on standards you really
don't need
us to tell you to work on standards i
think you guys know how to do that
i think that was part of the issue right
gordon tina and i have these ongoing
conversations
and i don't know how many
years it's been tina may know since i
was
chairing the committee that was working
on how to fund the drug courts
which was in finance and turned out to
be
a lot of people because it was a
combination not only of division one
but members from division three as well
because there were impacts into that
area
we had a little trouble just getting
started
tina and i don't need to go through all
that but we
we did have some fits and starts not
sure we were going to get it passed but
we did
yes you were instrumental for sure one
of the things we did not do
hindsight's a wonderful thing so okay
let's start with that
we were just concentrating on how to get
the stupid thing going how to get it
funded
we thought it would make a difference we
never gave any consideration to
five years down the line six years down
the line all the costs will go up and
the money will be the same
so i had suggested to tina before the
pandemic hit
and then of course this summer we were
all someplace else so we never could get
together and work on it
but that we do a modification to the
funding
and at least add in a cpi
funding so the drug court money
continues to go up i still think that's
the way to do it
rather than trying to take money that
might have been used in a county that
doesn't want it
and put it out yeah so i'm um
i would like to work with you and tina
and get that bill filed in the fall
and make that happen rather than try to
deal with that here
that would be my preference okay that
makes total sense
that said house finance house ways and
means passes revenue estimates it tells
us what
we may spend in finance so that's
basically the first step of the budget
that was voted on in the floor of the
house when we met
at the bedford sports arena and
house ways and means voted unanimously
i respect them greatly i don't know how
to decide what revenues have but clearly
my role is spending the money
my husband sits on house ways and means
so you can imagine we have interesting
dinner conversations about i need more
money and he's like cut
yeah okay it's the same reason i don't
drive a ferrari because he and i have
those conversations at dinner and the
money just never shows up
but we the house
has to cut a minimum of 49 million
dollars
if we use rainy day funds to manage
whatever overspending we have for this
year we are clearly moving out of the
pandemic
covet is going to be endemic the thing
i'm looking forward to most
is not being tested every four days by
my employer
so yeah i'm covered free but you know
i'm tired of being tested
that's hard i am not going to cut your
budget i have worked out the division 1
share
of cutting the budget and your budget is
going to pass
i don't think i can add on the money
tina wants for the drug courts i
apologize
but you're basically going to get your
budget through here
without any additional cuts
and that's kind of where i am but i
would like to work on getting
increased funding for drug courts what
we did is not sustainable year after
year
i appreciate that madam chair and and uh
justice nato and i will
will engage with you and and figure out
a way to get it on a sustainable
um glad path going forward okay really
important program and
i thank you for your your work and
getting it off the ground
now you have to promise to tell jane la
jane young we ripped you over the colts
and you had to give up lots and it was
difficult because otherwise you're going
to come after me
madam chair i just want to say i'd like
to co-sponsor that bill with you on the
drug courts i'd be happy to work with
you
okay great thank you mary beth i
appreciate that
well i heard lambs and slaughter may go
back to that
and knowing how discerning the chair and
the other members of the division are i
can't believe you bought that for one
minute
yeah no she did start she was so funny
she did a really good job and she
started here and she said you know he
could have waited one more week and i
feel like i'm
a lamb going to slaughter here but she
did a good job
yeah they're getting all the positions
you put in i have had to push the start
dates a little bit
uh we haven't seen those amendments yet
but you're going to get your position so
your budget basically is going to pass
unscathed as well from where you left my
former that is the budget i did build
that is the budget you did bill i know
well i thank you madam chair and i thank
members of the division and
and we do have our letter and if there
are any questions at all i you know how
to find them
let me ask tina about this section tina
section 36
i mean section 16 the superior court
the number of judges serving on the
superior court shall not exceed 22 and
the number of full-time judges
shall not exceed 35.
yeah but then it says relative to
conversion of the position of marital
masters
to full-time judicial positions this is
hereby suspended do you need that
so here that oh that is judge
yes judge king so i that's been in the
last
several weeks i know i'm trying to fight
after you need it we have it again we
have to approve or disapprove all these
sections respectfully ask you to take it
out because my interpretation of that is
if one of our remaining two marital
masters retires we can't replace them
with a judge which we would need to do
so take it out that would be my
preference
okay i can do that then
donna is you transfer among classes
we have not approved that either
that is helpful language um you try to
be respectful though
of salary and benefit appropriation
even versus other language would give me
the ability to transfer
wherever from wherever to wherever
and i think it also increases the limit
to a hundred thousand dollars i believe
in statute it still remains itself i did
pass a bill that i failed to put
judicial branch in to increase the limit
so that was my fault but yes that
that bill passed oh representative
leishman has joined us with his broken
wrist
welcome back
okay so you need that yes
section 18 before you guys go i'm sorry
gordon you have your
do you have a question on 17 before
leave it no but i wanted
addressed section 16. okay address
section 16 please
the uh the number in section 16 with
respect to the circuit court
is 35 it needs to be increased to 37.
but if i delete that as judge king said
you have funded 37 do i need that in
there or
now this is a question are you
authorized 45 positions but some of them
are unfunded
yes so if i delete this section you're
oh i misunderstood you're going to
delete the entire well that's what i
is that what i heard you'd ask me to do
what i was asking
is the section that refers to marital
masters
would be such that if a marital master
retired
that current language would prevent us
from filling it with a judge
and that was done a few years ago and
it's been carried over just as a cost
saving measure but we would like to take
that out so that if
one of our two remaining marital masters
retired we would be able to ask
that position to be filled with the
judge but we do need 37
cap in house but wait a minute i have a
very simple
brain bear with me
gordon you told me you have
authorization for 45 circuit court
positions
35 were funded but you added funding for
two more
so you're still authorized for 45
positions with 37 funded are you not
we are authorized for 45 but there's
been a cap in hb2
but if i take this section completely
out then we would be fine
then you would be fine so my plan was to
delete
get an amendment to delete
section 16 in its entirety
that works i i misunderstood your
colloquy i thought we were just talking
about the marital
master language i i read the head the
olive and then i okay i got
and mr hoffman you hear that we need an
amendment to delete section
16 and hb2 okay now
let us move to the last section you guys
have here that i know of
section 18 the judicial branch
reimbursement of sheriff's office for
court security for the biennium ending
june 30th 2023
the state shall reimburse the sheriff's
office for court security
at the rates provided in the collective
bargaining agreement agreement
applicable to per diem court security
officers
that sounded fine to me we haven't
approved it yet
but that's okay
excellent i think we have it
okay so now you really are done oh
i'm sorry representative emerick has i'm
sorry you're not done representative
emerick is going to get out
these are not budgetary questions these
are issues we're dealing with here
one of the one of the issues uh has to
do with the affiliation of the parole
board
right the parole board is currently
married to the department of corrections
is it in the right place
i i'm i have no position on that i think
it's better directed to
ols is researching that and they have a
phone call
monday morning with somebody high up in
the
architecture of parole boards for the
okay i'll move on to my next measurement
okay move to your next one
two terms ago uh the chair and i visited
and it got a presentation about the
probate
system when it was being automated it
was very impressive
well when the program i believe was
probate
and they've continued since you've been
out right superior
so i i i i wasn't around i just wonder
what
additional strategies you're going to
employ electronically because there was
a plan
it seemed like we were doing it in
chunks big chunks and i just wonder what
what what's the next
big chunk or what are you working on now
okay i think it's
very impressive very superior court is
up aren't
tina aren't you guys up electronically
now with the e court
chief is it okay if i answer this or yes
when i don't see you um yes we the
superior court
is fully electronic in civil and in
criminal case types which
ironically helped us in the pandemic we
are now
working on a project to bring digital
evidence management to the courtroom so
that the lawyers when we first rolled
out ecorp were wondering well what about
my paper documents and my photographs
and my videos what do i do with that
so our next project in the ecorp project
is to roll out a digital evidence
management
product um circuit court did a whole
bunch of the sort of lead work with
small claims and wills and trusts
and worked out a lot of the kinks for us
so it helped us get
civil and criminal up and running we
have a smaller operation so it was
easier so the next piece is to complete
that by
bringing on digital evidence management
that's the next step
thank you one more one more
there's a another issue that we're
dealing with called sheriffs
and transportation of inmates
and right now that budget line is in the
department of administrative services
they come before us and we say what
about this budget line
and they say we we're unfair to
everybody
but we don't know how to manage this we
don't know how to take care of them
and so we're struggling right now with
how to how to how the reimbursements to
sheriffs
you seem to do a lot with sheriffs what
i'm trying to do is get you to take this
i can tell you former former supreme
court justice
before fred before bob lynn
i tried to do that i was six feet tall
at the time i'm now five
six so it was not well received
and this was not even at the requested
administrative services it just
when we got to that point of the budget
they they said
all we do is write checks i mean they
they really have no authority they have
no
involvement they're just a an
administrative check writer
and they don't have enough money so they
make disbursements until the money runs
out
and they would like you to take it over
and tracy would like you to take it over
and we've asked before and i think you
guys have told us
i know you guys have told us no i think
it was called pound sand
you have something like pound sand
go ahead sorry we kind of have the same
problem because they are not our
employees
we have the same problem of making sure
we're
keeping track of their time so the court
system pays
for their security in the courtroom and
das pays for their transportation
services
um you know unlike our court security
officers which are our
court judicial branch employees the
sheriff's
deputies who provide security in the
superior court
are sheriff employees and then we
immerse them reimburse them for the time
they're there so we have kind of a
similar
challenge we've worked really well with
them because of your
insistence rep over over the past budget
cycle to get them
and us on the same page about what are
the actual costs so we've had to work
very closely with them
donna went around and met with every
single sheriff's department to figure
out
all right let's make sure we tighten up
this budget so we kind of have the same
problem but donna is incredibly on top
of it from our end at least
the other the other observation i've had
representative is
what is the function sort of at a
constitutional point of view of
transporting
prisoners and i i don't i would have
great hesitancy to say that that is a
judicial branch function
certainly when they're in our facility
we work with the sheriffs to provide
safety and security when they're there
but actually getting them there i think
is more of an executive branch function
so this this ping-pong ball is going to
keep bouncing around for a while
it just see it seems like the sheriff's
is an archipelago of unmanaged
i mean every everybody's writing checks
but nobody's in charge
i did have to deal with this issue
myself and what sorry and what i ended
up doing a few years ago when the
contract
um the rate for them changed what used
to happen is
they would send to the judicial branch
the invoice for both
courtroom security as well as custody
and control and then we would send the
custody control piece over to your
report facilities
for them to pay i don't know why we got
that piece of it because we didn't pay
it
but when that and it used to be just a
very uh high overview of what they were
billing us for you know me hours they
were working individuals
so i completely overhauled our invoice
portion i had no control over what view
report facilities did
but i created a spreadsheet where i
could then see how many people
were working what days how many full
days how many the hours how many full
days how many half days
so it gave me a much better indication
of what type of
staffing resources they would provide
security resources they were providing
now
that having been said that doesn't mean
that they're doing it in the most
efficient manner right
and one of the things i noticed in um
the language
here is that the the metric that they're
trying to use i believe is population
and i'm not sure that that's the best
metric i think it depends on a lot of
things um for
us for court staffing um is number of
judges who are going to be serving in
that court the logistics of that port
sometimes make a difference as well
so and could there be a high profile
case what i ended up doing
was i analyzed the number of uh full
days and half days that each county
provided in the prior fiscal year to get
some kind of a
baseline then i some of them charge
different
benefits they don't all charge the same
amount the statute says they can charge
benefits that are associated with this
work but they don't all do it
consistently so i had to incorporate
that for the
for the sheriff's counties that did
charge it so then i got sort of a
baseline and i knew what percentage each
sheriff's county was providing of the
whole from the whole amount that we got
i backed out an amount as a reserve that
was the piece
that if one county went over their
allocation
i could say i'm taking it out of this
pot for now if i run out of money in
in the reserve entirely then i'm going
to have to go to a county that's go
that's running a surplus
and i'm going to meet with them and say
i gotta take some money out of your
budget
to cover the other county that's having
a shortfall for whatever reason
but that reserve again is gonna be used
for unexpected things a very high
profile case where they need
additional security that's what it's
meant to do um so that's the way i have
tried to manage this but it is
difficult to some degree i am still
writing checks but at least
i can track now when they send their
invoice and i actually have
spreadsheets that track how many full
days how many half days so that
and we haven't had an issue because of
the pandemic where anybody's exceeding
their allocation but if i can see trends
i project out and i can see if
somebody's going to be exceeding
their projection i can let them know and
their allocation i can let them know and
say
can we have a discussion about what's
going on and if somebody does exceed it
i'll need an explanation what's happened
what do we need to do because it's going
to affect some other county
but i have one pot of money to use so
that's how i have managed it
i'm sorry i asked
representative hatch you have your hand
up for a question yes thank you madam
chair and and
no i'm glad you asked because that
that's a concern and i think we do have
to come up with and i agree mileage that
our population makes no sense
um and thank you for your very good work
in
in allocation could we could you make
that information available to us that's
absolutely why i asked administrators i
would be more than happy to do
a total reimbursement to each county and
then take your figures
and maybe we can come up with a viable
reasonable
distribution uh factors if madam chair
would agree with that
thank you that's all whom should i
contact to do that
um are we getting something
what are we getting a summary from you
don i don't know what you're going to
give us
it's going to be an excel spreadsheet
that i would probably need to talk
someone through
i would love i would i don't think we
have time to do that we've got to get
this done the next day or two
um so i'm going to suggest that you and
represent hatch work on that as a
possible bill for next year to solve
this problem
because we unfortunately you guys are
here towards the end of the budget
hearing i mean we are
chunking along here but we are on a
house deadline
and we have a problem that we've talked
on
i've met with you guys a number of times
back and forth you've done work i don't
think we're going to solve it
in a day or two equitably i think
that work needs to be done i think
represent patch and represent to burge
understand and would love to work with
you on a possible bill for the fall and
see if we can't put this to bed once and
for all and come up with an equitable
way to do it
thank you madam chair and i'm easy to
find in my basement
thank you yeah so let's do it that way
gordon do you have a comment
are there any other questions i'm going
to take a couple of votes if you want to
stay
for them may i just as i'm new to this
role madam chair if you will just
indulge sure absolutely
when you when you when you read the
letter um
you will see that although i did not
build this budget i strongly support the
addition of
two additional circuit judges i did read
it why you what we've been sitting
here in fact i believe that a very
strong case can be made for
uh two more on top of that given we
don't have money for that you're gonna
get your two
no no and and i i recognize that
madam chair but i do i do hope that we
could engage in an ongoing dialogue
about
appropriate levels of uh of staffing for
judicial officers in the in the circuit
court i'd be happy to do that
thank you i'm kind of at a point where
as i said i'm not
i've managed to cut the amount we have
to cut without you guys coming in you're
so lucky
so we're taking care of you believe me
i'm not
i i just want to start as i'm starting
out i want to be able to have that
dialogue with
you and i've worked together before so
absolutely thank you madam chair
all right so guys section 17 page
nine is the judicial branch transfer
among accounts and classes
do i have a motion to approve that as
presented representative emerick moves
to approve that as presented represent
griffin seconds is there any discussion
on the motion
see none with the clerk please call the
rule if you're in favor
of approving section 17 you will say i
when your name is called
if you are not in favor say nay
okay madam chairman aye representative
emrick the clerk votes yes
representative griffin
yes reference leishman representative
hatch
represent walls yes okay seven nothing
it's unanimous madam turn
section 18 in house bill two also found
on page nine
is the reimbursement of sheriff's office
which ensures that they are reimbursed
at the collective bargaining amount
do i have a motion to approve
representative emerick moves to approve
representative griffin seconds
if you are in favor of the motion to
approve when your name is called please
say aye
if you're opposed please say nay
okay madam chairman aye vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin
represents leashman representative hatch
yes
representative walls yes madam chairman
the vote is seven nothing it's unanimous
vote is unanimous i would like to have a
motion to approve the judicial branch
budget as
presented representative moves
representative griffin seconds on the
motion to approve the judicial branch
budget
when the clerk is ready because we go
faster than any human
can write and we're not automated here
he will call the role if you're in favor
you will say aye
wait a minute mr hoffman you have your
hand up why do you have your hand up
i'm sorry to interrupt madam chair on
section 16
do you need a vote to delete that
section i don't have an amendment
but yes i will when you get me an
amendment i will delete it but i need
amendment number to put in the
in the motion okay so i'm depending on
you to do that later and they're going
to trust me that i get that done
i'm all set of your set on the motion to
approve the judicial branch budget
if you're in favor when your name is
called please say aye if you're opposed
please say nay
okay madam chairman aye uh vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative elishman
representative hatch hi rivers and walls
yes wrote seven nothing it's unanimous
motion
your budget is proof seven to nothing so
gordon
you and you and i are going to work with
tina on trying to come up with some
scheme
for funding the drug courts within
extra money every year and i'll be happy
to work with you on staffing as well and
whatever else comes up
but i trust me i will get section 16.
i can't end budget hearings till i take
care of every pesky section hb2 so i
have to do something but
i'm deleting it we'll get an amendment
thank you very much madam chair and
members of the division
you're welcome good to see you all tina
bye
thank you you're welcome
okay where's
uh
we're going to take a brief five minute
uh recess so please
mute yourselves and we'll be back in
five minutes
i have not seen it he has a copy mr
hoffman he wants to ask you a question
before he passes it out
so representative lee sherman take it
away thanks madam chair
uh mike these rsa references one of them
does
pertain to the uh lakes region
commission right
i believe so i'm going to ask nancy to
join since she worked with
ols and drafting of that amendment i
just want to make double sure yeah
the this draft amendment was based on a
language from the 2015 budget and it
does not reference the commission
because the commission formed after the
um this budget passed
that was a subsequent entity uh
lakeshore redevelopment planning
commission
which was to identify development
alternatives
um and they are still in existence at
this time they have a budget
appropriation but
i understood the intent of the amendment
was to
transfer the authority for sale that's
promulgated in house bill 2 from the
governor solely back
to a legislative input
without consulting the commission but i
can amend it if that's what you wish
yeah let's uh look at an amendment
thanks dance okay
okay so representative leishman you're
not ready to proceed with your amendment
is that correct
yeah i just want to make sure it
protects the commission that was
established
that's fine with me that's your
amendment that's the reason i ask thank
you
we're going to look at and i haven't
seen these
yet but the technical correction
to the liquor commission i have an hb1
amendment that was just handed to me if
we can get that up on the screen
and if lba would walk us through that
okay
it's warm in here today after weeks of
freezing
it is warm in here
it's 60 outside so
and the wind isn't blowing so the
curtains aren't ruffling because the
wind's blowing through here
all right we have up on the screen and
would lba please talk about this
amendment
yes yesterday when we heard from the
liquor commission
um one of the pages of their handout
included
a technical correction
moving money from one class line to
another with
with no increase or decrease
this would move money into class
which is a maintenance contract
for their microsoft d365 software
program
from the class 103 which is contracts
for
operational services
any questions by anyone on the division
about this
this is an hb1 amendment it's an errata
sheet
representative emerick moves to adopt
the liquor commission errata sheet for
their software representative griffin
seconds the motion is there any
discussion on the motion
if not if you're in favor of the motion
to adopt the errata sheet for the
liquor commission when your name is
called please say yes
when if you are in favor if you're
opposed please say no
okay madam chairman yes the vice
chairman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin lischmann
representative hatch yes representative
walsh yes
seven nothing it's unanimous madam
chairman motion passed seven to nothing
okay let's see what else i was handed
this morning
i now have in my hand
a department of justice
change that needs a little discussion
for me
mike if you can bring up the department
of justice this deals with the
governor's budget
page 277.
a companion hb2 amendment is being
prepared is that correct mr hoffman
um that is i'll have to double check
i don't know if my house bill 2
amendment for this is necessary
okay so this may be without an hp 2
amendment thank you
this proposes to delay the start of
two of the three new attorney positions
from july 1 2021
to january 1 2022
it is not likely that the
doj would be able to hire three
attorneys at one time
as you know we have to make some budget
cuts this actually
provides a savings in the of almost a
hundred and seventy eight thousand
dollars
but still allows them to have the staff
members they have asked for
just a six-month delay for two of the
staff members
discussion of the proposal
madam chair yes mr hoffman sorry to
interrupt
happy to have the interruption the
savings are
in uh fy 22 in the amount of 44
000. oh i misread the line thank you
i looked at the wrong column yes
represent emmerich moves to adopt the
delay start of two of the three new
attorney positions
represent griffin seconds if you're in
favor of the motion
when your name is called police say yes
if you're opposed please say no
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes
sorry clerk votes yes representative joe
griffin yes representation
representative hatch yes represent walls
yes
the vote madam chairman's having nothing
it's unanimous thank you
mr hoffman let me ask you a question
do we have anything outstanding on the
justice department budget or have we
handled everything for them that is in
hb1 i know we have they've asked to have
three sections deleted in hb2 and that
amendment is coming
but just from an hb1 perspective are we
at a point where we could approve that
budget
yes i believe we've dealt with
everything in house bill 1.
okay so on the justice department budget
we've added and done what we want to do
we still have sections coming on hb2
remember they asked to delete
three sections and we looked at that
yesterday and we will get that amendment
is there a motion to approve the doj
budget
representative moves he's their second
representative griffin seconds
any discussion
okay see none if you're in favor of the
motion to approve the doj budget
you'll say yes when your name is called
if you are not you'll say no and the
clerk is ready to call the rule
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
representative hatch yes represent walls
yes
the vote is seven nothing madam chairman
at unanimous
okay this afternoon let me tell you
what's happened with some of those
sections you guys were interested in
this afternoon matt malou
the governor's budget director and chris
elms
are going to come and talk about the
department of energy
then matt malou i don't know if chris
helms will come back
but dj bettencourt will be back
next monday to talk about the family
leave sections
and at one of those times we will have
matt depending how long we run
run through the executive the governor's
budget
i know we have interest in both
department of energy
and the family leave but because
dj betancourt is not available this week
that has been pushed off until monday
i'm sorry tuesday i've got in my head
we're doing this every day of the week
so it's in the book for tuesday morning
so i just want you to know that when
they come this afternoon
it is only the energy situation not the
family leave which i know people have
shown some interest in doing
we did not approve the agricultural
markets and food department budget
either
mr huffman do we have any outstanding
issues on that i don't remember any
in hb one i don't believe we have any
outstanding issues we had one um
house bill 2 section that we looked at
and
i think we approved that yesterday
didn't we yes we did approve
section 51.
so i believe if you would like
agriculture has nothing outstanding in
house bill one
do i hear a motion to approve the budget
representative emerick moves to approve
the agricultural budget represent
griffin
seconds is there any discussion of the
motion or what was presented by that
agency
madam chair ruby's of walls um
i just said the clerk thanks you because
he's writing as fast he can to try to
keep up so
so thank you um i'd like to point out
that we heard testimony
i mean i will vote to approve the
agricultural budget but i'd just like to
point out that we heard testimony that
they are understaffed
that they cannot meet their legal
obligations when it comes to weights and
measures
that there are legitimate issues with
the level of funding we're providing for
them
and so i just want that acknowledge that
we are going to fund them but we are
underfunding them for what they need to
do to meet their basic statutory
obligations
thank you
i think we're ready i just see no other
hands uh if you
are in favor of the motion to approve
the agricultural budget
if this is when your name is called
please say yes if you're not please say
no
madam madam chairman is this hb1 this is
hb1
okay thank you madam chairman votes yes
vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative schmidt leashman reverend
hatch
yes represent walls yes the voters have
nothing
madam chairman it's unanimous
okay i would like to talk a little bit
about
natural and cultural resources
department
we have an open hb2 section which we
looked at briefly
yesterday we went through their budget
her primary requests for things that
were not included
were what was in hb2 but she made no
requests for the hb1 section
mr hoffman do we have any hb1
issues outstanding for natural and
cultural resources
madam chair yes i don't believe we have
any
outstanding house bill 1 issues but
there
is a bit of a
problem in division 2 where there's some
transfer
lines going into the agency's budget
that they
from the department of transportation
that they're going to be resolving in
division two
because very little impact here but i
did make division two
we've been working together on that
what is the impact on the budget we have
nothing nothing no
okay so i think we then
could approve the natural culture
cultural resources department's hb1
budget
representative wait a minute
representative emerick moves
representative lee
i mean represent griffin seconds and
representative walsh has discussion
representative walls please yeah i was
just looking at my notes on this and
as i recall there was a question about
the fort stark project isn't it that is
in hb2
thank you i couldn't remember where it
was i didn't have um
no that's legitimate let's just double
check that
section i think it's in hb2
if i can find the section we'll look at
it before we vote
nancy do you know off top of your head
what that section is
madam chair yeah i seem to be having
deja vu for this didn't we do this once
for first start fund it fort stark was
put
in the budget by division one
last year at three hundred thousand
dollars
i did not sit on the committee of
conference
i do not know if it was removed in the
senate
or removed in the committee of
conference but i was
assured by lba that this was removed
from
the budget okay thank you madam chair
just
just my mom who who in this division sat
on the committee of conference last
last time
i don't think any of us
oh that's helpful isn't it
you're all being punished for something
um
no
why can't i not find that section
oh bingo section 142 page 62
please turn to hb2 page 62.
let's verify this
that's it that's what i was referencing
okay so now the sections i think we're
really looking at
are at the top of page 63.
fort stark has grown by 50 to six
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
last year it was three hundred
the second section so there are there
are five
five programs in here
section one which is found on line three
is six hundred fifteen thousand dollars
for fort stark which includes
security and safety improvements
parking lot improvements two family
bathrooms in a new building adjacent to
the oms
building extension of the municipal
water service to the toilet building
a new septic system demolition of the
harbor entrance control post building
and the cleaning and securing of bunker
tunnels rooms and entryways
mr hoffman your hand is up
thank you um we have been asked to
prepare an amendment
yes i know that we we don't have yet uh
yeah i know
okay um
since i asked for the amendment i know
yeah i'm going to talk about that in a
minute so section 2 is the sum of 655
for the purpose of redevelopment
improvement projects at the jericho
mountain beach
area campground including an rv dump
station two new pit toilets
ten campsites four camping cabins
extension of water to the beach area
extension of electrical utilities to the
beach area campground
winterization of four camping cabins and
four
trailer sites excuse me
the commissioner said this would
generate some income
now she's asking to spend general fund
dollars when the parks are usually
funded
from the parks fund so we would be
putting general fund dollars into this
she would be generating
income into the parks fund
when i ask for the amendment this is one
of the projects i asked to have retained
in the amendment
then section 3 is the sum of 347
thousand dollars to upgrade
the hampton rv park and again if you
recall she talked to us about the fact
that
the service upgrade needs to be done
because it
the current rvs cannot connect
to this older out moded
infrastructure
the fourth section is the sum of 150 000
for the purpose of constructing new
playgrounds at two state parks
the fifth section is the sum of 250 000
for design engineering preliminary site
work for
facility upgrades at the ragged neck
picnic area at rye harbor state park so
i left
i asked mr hoffman for an amendment that
leaves
sections two and sections three but
deletes
the other three sections this is an
expenditure that is
well over a million dollars and even
those two
sections spends approximately a million
dollars
while cutting off close to another
million dollars
of general funds the commissioner does
have park
funds she could do some of those things
within those parks using her park funds
without general funds
but none of those were in her
hb1 budget so i think we can
safely we you don't have the amendment
in front of you i haven't seen it i
asked for it
late last night lba is magical but when
you ask for things in the middle of the
night
you don't necessarily see them right
away so i think we could
approve the hb1 budget
of natural and cultural affairs and we
do have a motion
on the floor representative wallace i
hope that answers your question in more
detail than you wanted
well i'm happy to have that detail madam
chair so thank you
okay then the clerk is ready to call the
role if you're in favor of approving the
natural and cultural resources
hb1 budget please say yes when your name
is called if you're not please say no
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes representative griffin
yes
representative leitchman yes
representative hatch yes
represent walls yes madam chairman the
voter 7 nothing it's unanimous
thank you representative emmerich please
would these would these fall into the
capital budget budgeting process are
they
are not big enough i think they're too
small and that's why they come to us
for operational money because capital
budgets get bonded and then
you pay interest over 5 to 10 to 15
years
it it doesn't seem to me like it makes
sense to pay interest on
600 000 but i just it just seems to me
i mean to have that fort stark project
double in cost
is kind of not explainable
and why can't she clean and secure
bunker tunnels
rooms and entryways from the park fund
for example
i've seen that's operational i mean
that's operational that's what that fund
is for
and we just don't have enough funding
she could also build
one playground uh madame chairman
yes we just voted on what i mean hb1
budget in hb1 okay got it
and then representative emerick jumped
to hb2
okay i just want to make sure that we
covered both thank you
all right guys let's talk about section
one let's talk about the elephant in the
room
section one in hb two
which is the sheriff's
reimbursement
it's clear there is interest in working
on a better process
however i don't think
we're going to get that done between now
and next
wednesday
so in the interim we need to at least
approve
this section
representative emerick moves to approve
section one reimbursement of sharon's
sheriff's office representative
griffin's seconds
um discussion representative burge
please uh yes i mean i will vote yes in
the affirmative with reservations but
because i did the math if you look at
the cost the population of costs roughly
31 000
divided by 1.5 million in the state
we're lucky if we get 2 but i just
wanted that for the record
okay madam chairman thank you that's
fair i mean
this is going to be a difficult
situation hillsborough county as
representative leishman i know ends up
paying for two court facilities which
no other county does so in order for us
to transport
prisoners for the court you guys have
one van for your
counties my county has to purchase
maintain
maintain two vans so you got prisoners
going one way and one van
prisoner's gonna knee one way and
another man you guys have got maybe
three sheriffs with your van
we've got six out so it it's just
there's just no real easy way of doing
that i would
love for uh representative hatcher
representative to burge to really dig
into this with
donna raymond and the judicial branch
and see what they can come up with
but there is no 100
solution i think we're going to find
between now and next wednesday
and that's just a week away
thank you madam chair and i do agree
with that sentiment
okay so on the motion to approve hb
section one
if you're in favor you will say yes
if you are opposed you will say no when
the clerk calls the rule
madam chairman votes yes vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes represent
representative hatch yes represent walls
yes the voters have nothing madam
chairman it's unanimous
okay so on page one of my index
for hb2 i have still open
section 16 mr hoffman
is getting a amendment to delete that
section
section 19 which is representative
leishman's
amendment and he is just asked for
a correction to the amendment he's got
so i'm going to flip the page we're
going to hear
we have section 40 but we'll hear that
budget next week
that brings us to
section 42 and section 43
on page one
section 42 is
the suspension of revenue sharing
it was this section that got me involved
in reading the covet relief bill
the only thing i can say about doing
that
is it gave me a great appreciation for
the websites in the state of new
hampshire versus
the convoluted website of the federal
government when you try to find anything
i'm in favor of suspending this because
when we are faced with cutting
this is a relatively in some ways
easy cut because it's not cutting
a staff member who's got kids or family
it's not cutting programs for disabled
or programs for elderly
or cutting the courts so that they can't
process
their legal obligations in a timely
manner
however on the other side being a member
of a
a town as each of you are i know that
that means that the town
is not going to have some revenue
however the bill that was just passed by
the federal government
and i believe president biden will sign
into law
if you look on their website there is a
grant
a large grant made to each and
every town and city
i talked to the governor's budget
director about how that might be
distributed
and i was told that that would be a
direct
pass-through grant the money would come
to the state
the state would immediately pass it
through
to every town and city
so there's some good and bad things
about that my my town gets some money
your town gets the money
it's very clear that if you happen to
have
a representative in congress or in the
national senate
that your town got a whole bag full of
money
because i looked at the town of the city
of manchester
where chris pappas lives they're going
to get
44 plus million dollars
in one lump sum they will be able to
spend it between
now when it comes in the spring and
2024.
over on the seacoast where represe
congressman custer is who
is my congresswoman they're getting huge
chunks of money
so everybody's town is going to get a
lot of money
in a way that makes me feel better
because i'm going to vote to
support this suspension
but i know the towns are going to get
some money so if you haven't checked
that out
on the fed's website i urge you to check
out your town
this morning i emailed my county
we're getting 80 possible 80 plus
million dollars there are some little
strings there's a little formula in
there it's got to be 75
of your operating budget i think if i
read that correctly but i emailed my
county
administrator this morning and said
listen guys you have between now and
to fill it it's one-time projects what
do we need to upgrade at the courthouses
what do we need to upgrade in our prison
what do we need to upgrade in our
nursing home
let's get started so i think each of us
should probably check that out and do it
but in the meantime
i would like a motion to approve section
the suspension of revenue sharing
representative emerick moves
representative griffin seconds is there
additional
discussion on this representative
leishman please thanks madam chair you
did make a good point
uh i think the city of manchester is
going to get more money just by itself
than the entire revenue sharing for the
entire state so
i'll be supporting the motion
uh mary beth is waving i think her cell
phone at me
no i wasn't i'm sorry that was not for
you
i thought i was missing a smoke signal
and something else was going wrong
it was a smoke signal but not for you
thank you
[Music]
um representative tubers yeah i'm
anxious to look at the website because
coast county has 23 unincorporated
places and i was wondering how that
fits into the formula so i will
you could also ask your elected
representative
are you custer or pappas or custer
custer so you could contact your office
and ask her how she did that
okay thank you because i certainly
couldn't figure out some of that stuff
but i did
dig through it last night when you think
when i couldn't sleep okay so on the
motion to approve
section whatever section it is revenue
suspension if you're in favor please say
yes when your name is called if you're
opposed please say no
hey madam churn believe it or not i'm
caught up yes
okay madam chairman votes yes the vice
chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin representative leishman
representative hatch now represent walls
madam chairman the vote is five nothing
it passes
five to two the vote is five to two i
corrected that
representative walls oh i'm sorry
oh no four days in a row will kill us
all could lba help us with section 43
which is the liquor commission
processing of merchant cards
i believe this is a necessary section
but if we could just
walk through it we haven't talked it
they glossed over it quickly yesterday
but if we go section by section i'd
appreciate that
who's up for that i am madam chair it's
mike
okay mike
as i understand it um i think one of the
other might have been ways and means
committee also asked about this section
and the response was that they need this
language
in the event that there's some sort of
disaster that
might jeopardize their credit card
business so they need to be able to act
quickly to maintain
their processing of credit cards because
percent of their businesses either
credit or debit purchases
i think the interesting thing in section
one and represent leashman and
representative emery
sitting on fiscal
section one says implement necessary
business strategies in the event of a
disaster loss of services
okay that sounds great but then
when at the end of line 29
the commissioner shall report to the
fiscal committee of the general court
within 30 days of any instances
where it would need to implement such
business strategies including
any costs and loss of revenue associated
with the disaster or loss of services
mike has this been in hb2
over and over uh yes
i believe it started in 2015.
that's what i thought dude does anybody
remember
them coming to fiscal committee and this
is supposed to
allow them to process when they don't
have
can't process credit cards there must
have been a time since then
when there was no electricity and they
couldn't process credit cards i cannot
think of a time when they reported to us
i don't recall seeing a report either
and i guess section two
of this law just using my i.t background
section two sounds to me like a time
when let's say there's a direct like
lightning strike in a shopping mall
where there's a liquor station
and now you need a long-term contract
with somebody technical who will host
your
i.t services at the location and do your
credit card processing maybe from a
trailer in the parking lot because there
are a lot of companies that provide that
backup service
for those kinds of technical issues i
can't think of whatever else that would
be but
this section seems to me to be
relatively benign and probably we should
approve it what do the rest of you think
herbert's in griffin is your mic on
represent walls won't hear you if your
mic's not on madam chair
i'm wondering what what rsa 176 says
does that limit
the size of the contract okay mr hoffman
the question is what is rsa 176 colon 18
and does it
limit the size of the contract and that
is line
34. i'm pulling it up but going from
memory
i believe it addresses competitive
procurement
176.
yep 176 18.
the title of that section is contracts
entered into by the liquor commission
it says contracts in excess of ten
thousand dollars
made or entered into by the commission
including but not limited to
warehousing transportation advertising
shall be
competitive competitively billed
reviewed by the attorney general and
approved by the governor
council before becoming effective
so represent griffin gives us a very
silent thumbs up and
i know people at home can't hear his
thumbs going up and down but that's what
he did
represent to burst yeah thank you madam
chairman i'm not an i.t
specialist but i know that there are
internet
providers servers that you know
do this for us i mean i don't know is it
an overlap here am i missing something
i think with it what they're talking
about in case of a disaster they would
have the ability
to go out immediately and do that
without coming and asking somebody
permission
okay thank you for that clarification
because we they do have
a lot of i.t support from doit but say
there was a lightning strike close to
them it could fritz
a lot of electrical components and it
might not be a case of bringing up a
store
but having the electrical company out to
do transformer replacements whatever
that can take a while
so represent griffin would you like to
move this section to be approved and
representative emery can
second it for you so move madam
oh okay so on the approval of section
42 in hb2 represent griffin
moves excuse me 43
i am looking two lines up i got the
wrong section
representative griffin moves to approve
section 43 represent
emirich seconds any additional
discussion thank you
madam chairman i'm in the same boat you
were always looking at section 42.
this is section 43 if you're in favor
of yes okay madam chairman yes yes
vice chairman the clerk votes yes
representative griffin
representative leishman representative
hatch yes
representative walls yes and the vote is
seven nothing madam chairman it's
unanimous
all right you can't go through a session
without
something that resembles a horse that
goes out after dark
represent wall so you do you have your
hand up because you don't know what a
horse that goes after
out after your dark is well i i'm not
sure i do madam chair
it's called a nightmare
we have a wee tiny nightmare and
representative
emmerich is going to move and i am going
to second
to rescind our vote on adding the das
positions yesterday um lba has found
a kind of significant
issue with that work is being done on it
but that amendment needs to be backed
out
so that work can continue and this is
our nightmare
of the session which is easily repaired
we hadn't gotten to the end
so on the motion to rescind our vote on
the das positions from yesterday
if you're in favor you will say yes mr
hoffman
you have your hand up would you like to
vote or would you like to speak
well i don't want to vote but uh are you
sure
i do want to apologize because i was a
bit hasty bringing those amendments
over yesterday it happens
it's done it's a nightmare we're going
to rescind it and i know that work is
ongoing so
it is what it is
thank you yeah the bundle
so we're we're moving forward with with
dealing with our little
horse that goes out after dark right now
so if
mr clerk if you're in favor of
voting yes on the re rescinding the
motion so that we can get our
little horse that goes out after dark
back into the barn
police say yes if you're opposed please
say no madam chairman
yes vice chairman yes the clerk protests
representative griffin
representative leishman representative
hatch yes
represent walls yes the vote is seven
nothing unanimous madam chairman
thank you
madam chair could i ask mr hoffman a
quick question on
revenue sharing i just i would love for
you to ask mr hoffman a quick question
while i try to figure out what i'm going
to do next
it looked like a good time to ask um
mike could you remind us again that the
the maximum amount for revenue sharing
is it like 12 million or
what the maximum amount that we if we
didn't suspend it
i'm going to ask nancy she did some work
on that
um looking into the background so no
it's not huge dollars but
you know significant in a way but 12
million a year or something it is 25
million
per year 25 million okay
so manchester is going to get 44 million
out of this
and that 25 million went everywhere
right that's
that was my thought when i said what i
did because the significance of the
federal money will far surpass what the
state would ever hand out under revenue
yeah okay thanks thanks mike
all right we we have on page starting on
page 45
it's sections 100 and 101 and i'd like
we haven't talked about those if lba
could walk us through those two sections
one of them is just an effective date
but section 100
has some new language
you'd like me to take a stab at that oh
somebody i would like somebody to take a
stab at that because i'm not
so please yeah this is the statutory
um bump in the meals and rooms tax
in the biennium which can amount to up
to 10 million dollars
for a biennium if that provision is not
suspended
and so i believe this section um
perhaps that amount um
from the prior year so that
um
it's essentially a free so that if the
rooms and meals tax
um does not increase there's no
additional revenue distributed i believe
it's just a way to cap that
accelerator okay so
this does a capping of something we've
had in hb2
yeah you normally um often suspend this
or just give five million dollars over
the biennium so in
one of the two fiscal years rather than
5 million each year
so this would add a statutory change to
that rather than
fixing it in house bill 2 as chapter law
each year
that would be a blessing because then
we'd have less
things to do discussion that lba can
answer
adam chair yes it looks like this
it looks like the bolded language is the
new language and that's correct to me
like this is a recognition
of what happened during the pandemic
with the rooms and meals taxes dropping
so much
and trying to make policy consistent
with the reality of what's happened over
the last year
is that a fair assessment i would agree
with you but nancy is that a fair
assessment
i think so i'd have to look at it more
carefully to see um if there's any i
don't believe there's an adjustment
down i think it's just up normally so
um only if the meals and rooms tax
increases 75
of that income is distributed not to
exceed 5 million
but i think i'm not sure what effect
this actually has if there is
if you didn't have that bolded language
and there was no increase
it doesn't automatically happen so
um i'm not sure what the intent of that
language actually is
because if there is no increase there is
no percent increase to be added
perhaps it's belts and suspenders yeah
could be it doesn't um
yeah as you read the regular language it
doesn't allow for
um a decrease so maybe they're just
trying to make clear that
that that would not happen but i'm not
sure it has any real effect here
all right seen that can have a motion to
approve
sections 100 and 101 since they're tied
together
represent hatch moves represent griffin
seconds
on the motion to approve sections 100
and 101
if you're in favor you will say yes when
your name is called
if you are opposed you will say no and
the clerk will call the role
madam chairman yes vice chairman the
clerk of ts
representative griffin reverend leishman
representative hatch
yes representative walsh yes madam
chairman of vote seven nothing it's
unanimous
okay could we look at section 121 which
is on pages 53-55
fifteen
all right section 121 it says it's on
page 53 it doesn't go anywhere else
it says if for for doit if a position
is unfunded
they can fill it as long as they don't
overspend their budget
do i read that correctly lba
yes that is correct their budget for
um positions yes
biennium right
it doesn't say class 10 and class 10 i
mean click 10 or 11 though
it does say personnel services
does that include moving benefits money
around
yes yes
salary and benefits for personnel
services yeah
the fifth language has been used for
other agencies as well
yes we did look at fiscal committee
language and there was a concern that
because the department of health and
human services has
special this sensation that this might
somehow be
um not possible but
we did discuss it in the office and we
didn't see any issue with this language
applying to this department as well
it would be benefits and whatever and
the reason they need that is there
is a state law that prohibits them from
transferring any money
out of their benefits line or their
personnel line so he couldn't
without that he couldn't move the
benefits around to help it
to do what he wanted to do
all right representative emerick moves
to approve section 121 represent griffin
seconds
is there discussion on that
seeing none if you're in favor of the
motion to approve section 121
you'll say yay when your name is called
if not you'll say nay
madam chairman yes the vice chairman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin
representative leachman representative
hatch yes
representative walls yes madam chairman
the vote seven nothing it's unanimous
okay
i want to move to
all right mike and nancy which which one
of these
workers comp sections we have 128 and
one of those mr mayorfield is still
working with a
drafting attorney on language is my
understanding i've lost track of which
one
refresh my memory that would be
section 128 okay could we perhaps then
look at section 129 which is on page 57
because i'm going to hold on that until
we work it out represent walls
pointed something out that i think we
need to resolve before we move on
madam chairman i have been in regular
correspondence with
uh commissioner maryfield and we've
agreed on language it's just in the
process as soon as it's prepared
i don't think ols liked the language and
there's a little more to it mary beth
okay i just ken maryville gave me
language and that sounded good to me i
said great i'm not sure what happened
after that
i'm amazing we've seen we have no
amendment i'd say something is going on
so we'll move to section 129 and we'll
leave that one open
yes ma'am chair i think that was one of
the later emails to ols
last night
okay can you guys one of you guys walk
us through
what is going on in 129 i see
some language taken out there must be a
federal reason for that it seems to
go with the federal law
i believe that's what the commissioner
said when he when he was in that they
were trying to align things with
federal requirements for that section
so apparently the council no longer
needs to meet quarterly if you look down
at line 31
it just needs to be as often as
necessary
and we're encouraging standards but
we're
taking away some other stuff and you
turn up to page
58 they are striking
line eight
which then renumbers all of the sections
they're striking lines 15 16 and 17.
line 33 we're going from you shall
make a report to you may make a report
so we know nobody will make a report
right
do we do we even need to think about
that
we turn the page now we're on page 59.
we see some more strikeouts
and again we're striking out some of the
standards no more minimum standards
so i wanted this kind of interesting
they're striking out a statement that
apprentice show would not be less than
16 years of age
on page 60
they're striking out considerably more
and i'm chairman do we know is all of
this required by federal law or is some
of this just policy that department of
labor is trying to implement
he testified that it was all to bring
him in alignment with current
federal law thank you
i mean line 32
is an increase in a funding mechanism
and i imagine that is it had changed in
federal law and you see
another increase in line 35.
madam chair those two sections are are
relative to unemployment compensation
and we'll be
good we're in section 130 all right
we're out out of ours
later today yeah we have to deal with
that later but they're coming later
today
so we stop at line
27.
and i'm chairman i'd like to say some of
this looks questionable but i don't want
to fight the
commissioner if he's just trying to
comply with federal law it still seems
questionable to me
yeah i i think you get into some of
these
situations where you have to trust that
people know what they're doing
representative leashman were you going
to say something
yes madam cheers i've
been known to say if i feel a little
uncomfortable with something i usually
vote
no and i'm not clearly comfortable with
all this so
if there is a motion to pass i'll likely
vote no
so what do you guys need to make you
comfortable because if we don't vote
this we need to tell him to get it down
here
immediately like next tuesday
and maybe some sort of correspondence
madam chair that says specifically this
is to
put us in line with federal regulations
mr hoffman can you tie contact mr
merefield and say there are a couple of
members who would like
clarification whether everything in line
in section 129 is to bring us in
alignment
with current federal law and if not
if he would clarify why the things that
are not there
are not bringing us in compliance with
federal law
need to be done and give him a deadline
of getting that to you on monday
absolutely would you prefer a document
or would you
prefer that i mute myself and try to get
him to join the meeting now
a document madam chair representation
would like a document i think he is
thinking lunch
okay i will do thank you madam chairman
she knows me all too
representative yeah i always have
reservations when they
change shell to may uh on page
58 um as regarding a biannual report
you know i'm always one for transparency
and this kind of bothers me a little bit
that means there'll be no report come on
let's face it yeah well yes i just
want to make sure that was clear thank
you
and if there was i'm not sure anybody
would read it just saying
um let's talk about the department of
corrections
and hb1
we have been able to
fund their vocational training
given what we have to cut and what we
would have to do
i see no way for this division
to do anything with their transitional
housing
the reality always is for the budget
the budget i think of the budget as a
football game with four quarters the
trouble is the quarters aren't the equal
15 minutes
so the governor's had his phase we're
quarter to the house
we have to have the budget out of
finance i believe that
chairman weiler will have an exec
session on the budget
on thursday march 25th
because the house deadline is to have
everything out by april 1st
which wraps around to the beginning of
the next week and you have to write the
blurb so he needs to have
that done so that will be the end of the
second quarter
we will not have march revenues yet
we will not have april revenues when we
know
the business taxes come in and if we are
getting out of this pandemic and we see
the improvement
the business tax revenues will go up
so we know this senate will have more
money than we have it is a fact of life
in fact in some cases
we can we count on that when we have to
make some tough
cuts we leave like we did in the
treasury leave a dollar behind so it's
easy to put the money in
although i'm happy to say that the covet
bill that was passed in congress
has all kinds of money for scholarship
for college kids so
we may not be so bad as we were i can
just see
i'm sorry no way to do anything with
transitional housing
and i've spent a lot of time looking at
it looking at that budget
so at this point in time
their hb1 budget
could probably be approved
except i
have asked lba to get an amendment
and i'm going to cut
the compensation for the parole board
from thirty thousand to twenty thousand
for thirty six days
of meetings in a year but
even doing that small cut which is ten
thousand dollars
times five members
you don't get enough money to do
anything
with transitional housing and i
think many of us sitting around the
table were very concerned with
transitional housing
i mean mary beth has mentioned a couple
times i was
appalled we asked the commissioner
so i'm at a point where once we work out
the parole board
this budget is going to be done for me i
just i'm sorry but i can't think of any
way
to fix that i'm open to suggestions if a
division member has one
that's what i'm doing in some ways i'm
hoping for the third quarter i'm hoping
the revenues turn around
and it would be nice if we could be the
third quarter for a change and have the
more money
but we don't so now the thing is how can
we do the best
if the revenues turn around it's easy
for the senate to put them back in we
were already wishing we could
adam chair yes i am extremely
sympathetic to what your position is and
to the efforts that you made in
restoring the educational cuts
however it's so clear to me from all the
terms i've served in the legislature
that without the transitional housing
our recidivism rate is going to climb
significantly and end up costing us a
lot more
money in the long run do you have a
study on that we could read
i would really appreciate seeing a study
with some stats on that
i don't at my fingertips i'm sure
they're out there and if you
want i can try and start reaching out to
find something that says that but i i
you know i've said on the the um
intergovernmental
brand i'm forgetting names of the
commission all the commissions i've said
on here
but i've heard this kind of testimony
over my 13 years in the legislature and
you know it's resonating even if i can't
point to a study as i said here at the
moment
what would you cut to fund that well i
can't say that off the top of my head
i'm not as intimately familiar but i'm
sure there's something in here that we
can do
and i um we can i can start
doing a hot and peck if you'd like and
make a suggestion but i'm telling you
that
this i know we're not a policy committee
but this is
a policy that's going to come back to
bite us it's much like we cut the mental
health budget and it came back and cost
us a fortune if we cut this it's going
to come back and cost us a lot in
additional
corrections costs and i i i'm not trying
to make this
anything about you madam chair i
understand the position you're in i
understand what you've gone through
but honestly i would beg that we find
something to restore
transitional housing because it is such
a cost saving measure in the long run
okay let's
let's be clear we did not a hundred
percent unfunded transitional housing
i know you're talking about restoring
transitional housing
in manchester the city of manchester and
i
think much of the money that was taken
out of manchester
was actually at the request of mayor
craig
who has been very vocal about not
wanting it
so we do have some transitional housing
i hear what you're saying
i do not have a cut i do not have an
idea and
i don't think another division is going
to cut money to give to us although i
have to tell you i did reach out to
karen and jess i mean what the heck
why not try to poach money so i hear
what you're saying
i want you guys to know where i am i
mean
i've always tried to be really honest
with you and don't wait till last minute
have you think well it's coming it's
coming no i can't find any way to do
that
and i'm not going to vote it today
because of the parole board situation
this was really just kind of
um telling you
where we were so i appreciate the
comments
and i appreciate the heads up that's
very helpful to know what's coming and i
appreciate not having it as a surprise
um i just it's important to me as a
matter of policy that i think that it is
one of those things that saves the state
substantial amount of money recidivism
is very expensive
and and i would just like to do some i i
would hope that as best as possible
this budget would reflect things that
look at the big picture
and do not cost us additional money in
the future but i
again i'm very sympathetic to where
madam chairman is i
understand exactly where what you're
saying
representative leishman you have a
question yeah man i'm sure i
i do recall reading or hearing and maybe
we could find out specifically but i do
recall that the elected officials the
mayor of manchester have said they
didn't want such housing in their city
because there was talk about using even
the sununu center
and there was great outcry against using
the sununu center so
that that's out there mary beth so we
need to track that down
but the other transitional housing unit
being cut is right here in concord and
there's no objection from the city of
concord i think they'd be happy if was
it shay farm
continues this transitional housing
there yeah if i had money
representative walls i i hear you i
the reason we're having this discussion
is i cannot come up with a
creative suggestion so what another um
another budget we haven't approved
is the judicial council
representative leishman moves to approve
the judicial council
representative griffin seconds if you're
in favor of approving the judicial
council budget
you will say i when your name is called
if you're opposed you'll say nay
and the clerk will call the rule
madam chairman for class of
clarification this is hb
2. this is hb1 judicial council budget
got it okay thank you madam chairman we
have to we have to
approve each budget and hb1 separately
okay thank you very much
okay madam chairman votes aye vice
chairman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes
representative leishman represent hatch
yes
represent walls yes madam chairman of
the vote
seven to nothing it's unanimous
oh i i have these i have these scratched
off as yes
did i send you that last night i think i
sent you this last time
you're like me you didn't read it late
so madam cheer
uh just before we go too far from the
judicial council i did request and
the folks did provide me with what
fiscal had approved
uh over the last biennium and it was uh
1.6 million dollars so it's clearly
you know what we're able to do and
they'll be perfectly covered
yep okay
the department of energy we're taking up
at 12 30. so
we're about to take a lunch break for my
two
reps at home this is a heads up
i am buying lunch for the division for
the members who are here in room 202
next wednesday which i think is the last
day we're meeting
i know you two are at home i understand
that i just didn't want
to do that and have you say to me well
why didn't you tell me i might have come
in to buy lunch so
i there's there is no star trek with
scotty
that says that can beam people lunches
papers from point a to point b when you
want to ship them around
so this is just an informational
announcement if you want to join us
in the room 202 on wednesday i need to
know
by tuesday so we can get your lunch
order
otherwise we will be taking lunch and
having it here
you guys will be taking lunch at home as
normal so thank you madam chairman i
will say that
i will not be fully inoculated by that
point so i'm going to decline your very
generous offer
but while i have your attention i also
wanted to let you know that the three
democrats on this committee have an
informational caucus at 1 30 that we
scheduled because there was nothing on
the schedule at that hour
so we would appreciate it if we could
take a break at 134 in informational
caucus and then be back to you in time
to hear
um employment security since we have
people coming in
if they're still here we will continue i
understand you may need to
break from the room we are scheduled
morning and afternoon on each of the
days and janet's been doing the best she
can schedule so
we're going to take a recess and
mike do you want to just leave us up and
everybody mute and
turn yourself black and we're going to
do that here 45 minutes for lunch we'll
be back at 12
30. thank you
reconvene
and thanks to matt maylou
we can do one small thing he's been
he's gone he forgot something he's
coming back so before we start him
could everybody turn to page 185
nhb one please
okay i think people have quit shuffling
through their books so i think we've
gotten there
um page 185 is the executive council
which is 100 percent general funded
their adjusted authorized for 2021
was 261 331
this is basically the benefits workers
comp
in-state travel at the bottom of the
previous page on 184 when you open up
your book pages
you see the salaries for their assistant
the stipends that the executive council
members get
etc so they are not only flat
funded but for 2022 they are slightly
less
at 256 336 dollars
and then of course in 2023 we have that
infamous
27th pay period so the general fund
spending goes up ever slightly
to 268 847
they are basically a flat funded this is
stipends for the executive council
members and support for their
one-time assistant who works for them
can i have a motion to approve this
budget as presented
representative emerick moves to approve
the budget as presented representative
griffin votes to second is there any
discussion on the motion
scene none on the motion to approve the
executive council budget as presented
if you're in favor when your name is
called please say yes if you're opposed
please say no will the clerk please call
the rule
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman representative
hatch
yes representative walsh yes madam
chairman the vote seven nothing it's
unanimous
thank you very much i now would like to
welcome
two people matt malou i hope i
pronounced that last name right
the executive's budget director for the
governor's budget director and chris
elms who is the senior policy leader to
the governor
i have your title right chris
legislative director but i'll tell you
okay he's legislative director
um i don't think i promoted you so i'm
going to give you a legislative director
correct you guys are here to talk to us
in depth about
the department of energy which is a
reorganization
and as i understand what is done we have
taken
office of strategic information osi
the public utilities commission puc
we have combined them into a committee
but
we cut out and sent the planners to bea
which taylor caswell talked to us about
and we sent
two positions to das
so we kind of have a little mixture here
and you guys are going to walk us
through
how do you want to start do you want to
go through hb2 first you want to
i mean hb yeah h32 those sections do you
want to
go through your handouts first that that
i haven't looked at these i just got
them so for sure let me open them up
i think we would prefer to start with
the presentation which was sent
out earlier this morning okay from there
go line by line through hb1 and then
save hb2 for the end
okay we're amenable to that okay
excellent so you should see three
different items in your handout
one of them is a letter from chairwoman
diane martin
of the public utilities commission which
is an explanation to the methodology
they used
for one of the line items we'll cover
that in more
depth later but just so you know what it
is
uh the second three sheets are responses
to
questions that have been uh asked of
other presenters
yes they are just kind of the standard
that go out to every agency for division
one
um we aired on the side of caution and
answered those for you as well
i'm glad you did because we may need
them okay thank you so we can definitely
talk to those as well
uh and the last chunk is the powerpoint
presentation which is about 23 slides
okay um and i think from there we'll
jump right into it
i will start chair one by saying it's
great to hear that there's already some
basic level of understanding on what the
end goal
here uh really is and and why the
governor sees this as
a good path forward not just from an
organization and structure of government
standpoint
but also the policy objectives uh that
we hope to reach
uh so with that going to slide two
much in the same way that chairwoman
over just discussed
the office of strategic initiatives is
dissolved
by this proposal with its functions
split between
bea das and
the remainder reorganized into this
department of energy
the public utilities commission is
entirely reorganized
within the department of energy with the
existing adjudicative functions think of
the three commissioners that preside
over dawkins
they become a much smaller
administratively attached unit
that we'll go into more detail later
proposal is introduced does not make any
changes to the office of the consumer
advocate
or the site evaluation committee and
chairwoman i know you've had questions
about
potential work that could be done to the
sec through this process
and i'm happy to continue those
conversations today as well
but as introduced no no changes to be
made there
on slide three this is a brief overview
of osi
which exists within the executive
department it's one of the governor's
offices if you will
organized into the division of energy
and the division of planning
and osi has expansive duties currently
they do everything from the u.s census
to the national flood insurance program
at one point they did the governor's
scholarship program
in addition to being a pass-through for
federal energy grants
like fuel assistance and weatherization
this structure represents you have a
question yes yes i do management you
mentioned that the
census is done but i thought it was from
the department of commerce
with the u.s government yes so the if
the census is done
federally but each state has a point of
contact
that point of contact exists within osi
so again this is a very broad list it's
probably broader than just about any
agency in state government
and by allocating these different
functions to more appropriate
existing units of government we see both
efficiencies
potential for cost savings and overall
again a better
policy structure for the state to meet
its objectives
and what are those policy objectives
this is on slide four
one of the things that is unique to the
new hampshire public utilities
commission and if you talk to lawyers or
if you talk to people that regularly
appear there
the the pucs current structure enables
staff to occupy this dual role
where if i was a stakeholder
and chris was a puc staffer
we would both present arguments during a
docket
but then the puc staffer has the ability
to then
advise those commissioners as they make
their decision
it creates the potential for perceived
conflicts of interest
and what this proposal would do
fundamentally
is establish a bright red line you're
either an advisor
helping the commission come to a
decision or you're someone
that is working on the docket compiling
evidence
building the evidentiary record but not
both
this is a structure we see in other
states like vermont we see it at the
federal level
and essentially removes again any
perceived conflicts that might arise
from the current structure and just
another benefit tying into that
chris you have to pull that microphone
up remember we have two reps at home and
we have
sound problems under the best because
these air cleansing machines
that cleans the air every five times
every hour are wonderful but
tiny bit noisy gotcha well um
just to tie into what matt was saying
there related to that bright red line
um some of you if you've dealt with the
puc on
energy issues you might have found that
there are times when either a
commissioner
or a staff member has to recuse
themselves from a conversation
where they say i can't speak to the
issue that you're talking about because
i'm
i'm going to be ruling on it or i'm
going to be supporting that in some way
by creating this bright red line and
having this separate department it adds
a level of accessibility for legislators
and for others
uh stakeholders to be able to approach
and say if i want to talk about this
and and make my position known you know
and
and how that relates to the state's
interest i can approach
uh the department and and without fear
of
you know either being pushed aside or
not being able to talk to the
appropriate
uh individual so it it brings in i
you know at least in the conversations
we've had a great deal of legislative
accessibility
that can sometimes be um probably more
difficult
unless you want to you know get on the
lists uh for the puc and deal with
hundreds of emails and and try to figure
out when and where to jump in
so that was just related to what uh matt
was saying there
and and just to add on to that if you
have a constituent that has a question
about environmental permitting
right you call the commissioner of des
they can get you an answer
if that's a utility issue today you
can't call one of the commissioners
right they
are bound by ex party rules and by
creating this department with a singular
mission
focused on energy policy we believe it
adds not only
accessibility but also accountability
and that comes here in bullet point two
where under this new proposal
all leadership positions would require
governor and council approval
madam chairman representative leachman
please
so matt i'd like to back you up a little
bit where you talk about establishing a
bright red line you know the federal
judges they
rely on their clerks to write decisions
um federally the federal service
transportation board they've got five
members they rely heavily on their staff
so i'm
i'm a little confused what you said that
this separation between the so-called
judges if you will and not interfering
with staff and advising because
staff advises all these people as far as
decisions
absolutely that's a very good point
thank you for the question
representative
there are staff and we'll touch on this
later in the presentation
specifically in an advisory capacity
to these commissioners to help them come
to their rulings
but those individuals are fully separate
from the individuals that would
present a case before them so certainly
agree
that they need that advisory um
that advisory staff to help them come to
the decisions and
i believe it's on slide 23 you'll see
what that looks like
so yeah but sure
happy to do so because i want to clarify
any confusion that that might exist
you're welcome so under the current
structure only the puc commissioners
require governor and council approval
none of the division directors do
no one at osi requires governor and
council approval
under this new structure all leadership
positions
the division directors the commissioner
of energy the deputy commissioner of
energy
would go through that formal
confirmation process for a defined
term um again we think that is a step
forward from the current structure
and lastly on this slide this proposal
unifies all of those energy policy
efforts
within a single department rather than
being scattered in a couple different
places
on slide five we'll discuss the general
fund
impact and what's important to note is
that these agencies
are a very small portion of their
funding comes from general funds
but what does come from general funds
this proposal
creates roughly five hundred thousand
dollars in savings
over the biennium the vast majority of
the funds for this department
are federal funds dedicated funds or the
utility assessment
but it's i want to stress that through
this we are finding ways to reduce the
general fund draw
and we do that through creating
efficiencies you're essentially
eliminating a whole um executive branch
agency by by taking this step
which creates it chairman i have a
couple of questions i don't know if it's
appropriate to interrupt
i'm going to let you interrupt a minute
let me ask one question before you go in
matt when i look at this
and then and you may get to it
under the governor of phase recommended
i do not see the two people going to das
on that line so you're going to have to
figure out how to talk about that
but i'm going to let representative
walls ask her questions
represent walls please thank you very
much madam chairman
so you speak about the general funds
costs but
i believe that there will be an increase
cost at the puc side
and ordinarily that would be passed
through to the utilities that are
regulated
is there going to have to be an increase
in the cost in the pass-through to the
regulated utilities because
i noticed that this um creation of this
actually creates a bunch of new
positions
if they're not being paid for out of
general funds or if they've got
money out of the general funds how are
we coming up with the money for these
seven or eight new positions that are
buried in here
sure and we'll cover that on slide seven
as well
um but to respond to representative
ober's question
the two positions that go to das are a
hundred percent funded by
an endowment that's the conservation
land stewardship program
so there are no general funds tied to
either of those two positions
okay thank you mary beth hold that
question until we get until seven
i will recognize you then to make sure
you're getting your answer thank you
on slide six and this is where i would
like to refer to the letter from
chairwoman diane martin
at the puc which explains
there's an increase to class line 73
in 22 and 23 compared to the current
biennium
those dollars are allocated to the state
through the regional greenhouse gas
initiative quarterly auction
the puc projects that those auctions
will yield more revenue
the revenue the state receives is a
direct pass-through back to rate payers
in the form of rebates so while in the
budget book
if you look at the total for the
department of energy it looks like it's
increasing
several million dollars each year we can
tie
almost a hundred percent of that
directly to this
one class line that is a direct pass
through back to ratepayers
what's the class line on that so that's
class 73
in accounting unit 1887
which is on page 359 and when we get
into the
actual line by line of hb1 more than
happy to re-identify then
that at that point
any questions on that for right now nope
to slide seven so and to your question
representative walls
uh i do want to walk through where these
position numbers come from
and if you look at the total for the
department of energy
in the budget book you'll see in 21 and
82 established positions
if you look in years 22 and 23 you see
and 104. part of that increase
is a misnomer because of the way the
state
accounts for positions 12
positions of that increase are currently
existing
at osi but most of osi's positions exist
in a non-classified status
essentially they serve at the pleasure
of the governor but are they in class 11
when they're budgeted
yes so their salaries are accounted for
but through this transition they're now
either becoming classified
or unclassified employees
at which point their position gets added
to the budget system
and we don't show the people in class 11
in the position total at the bottom of
the page isn't that correct
that's correct mary beth does that
answer your question
i think you're muted no okay no i'm
sorry just a little slow to unmute
um so i'm i'm not following
i was just going back to the budget book
but my question still remains
will there be an increased assessment
against the utilities to pay for any of
these new positions
i think that's what matt is saying the
budget book
doesn't count all the positions we get
no
count on people in class 50 which is
part time
we really get no count on people who are
non-classified in class 11. so these
people have
been there and have been paid but the
budget book the way this
system works they never count so now
they're being put into class lines where
they will be counted
so it's the same number of people
but now you're seeing the total count
accurately
so i i didn't understand that madam
chair but i'm talking about the revenue
to pay for this because he said there's
going to be a
small cost against the general fund but
this is a large department
or small increase in the general fund
and for example the puc right now is a
100 percent pass-through of an
assessment against the utilities
and to do this transition and to have
the new positions in the puc and the
positions of the department of energy
and maintain everything
and as i read this there's something
like eight new positions in the
department of energy that don't exist
anywhere else
but at any rate to have all this my
question still is
is will the assessment against the
utilities have to increase
and thank you for the question
representative walls and i'd point you
to the chart where it says the net new
positions of 11
right those would be the new positions
that we're creating as part of this
reorganization
those positions would be funded
through the utility assessment
or federal funds or other funds and on
the questions that i submitted or
answers to questions i submitted that
we'll get to in a moment
i detail those funding sources in
the interim there would be a
moderate increase in the utility
assessment
to account for this transition but the
reason
why that has to happen is because we're
creating new positions that require
governor and council confirmation we
can't place
a classified individual in that role
so if anything there are more positions
that exist in the budget system
than we would ever actually want to fill
at this department
define moder mod modest increase is that
roughly 10 050 thousand a million what's
what's modest to you so that's roughly
1.5 million
during this transitional period of the
utility assessment
but again once people are confirmed into
those
governor and council positions or let me
put it this way
we're essentially double budgeting for
some positions
because we don't want to lay anyone off
as part of this reorganization
so we need to keep them in their current
role
we know that some people in the
department will raise their hand
to be a division director or to be a
deputy director for the
department but we we can't
not budget for their current role and we
know that they
would never occupy both so
it is an accounting function the
the glide path that we are on is once
you are through this transition
our intention is not to increase the
draw on the utility fund
it is not to increase head count we see
this as a way to get to efficiencies
but rather than trying to ram something
through
or potentially jeopardize people's
positions based on a timeline
we didn't eliminate those positions
prior to them becoming vacant
okay i guess i'm going to be devil's
advocate here and you're going to hate
that
you had no problem unfunding vocational
training in department of corrections
even though those
positions were filled and now they had
no money
you had no problem unfunding and laying
off people in doit
who were doing help desk work so those
weren't empty positions but those were
positions laying in them
and now you tell me you have a problem
doing it here i don't
understand how that tracks and do you
see where i'm coming from
i do see where you're coming from
representative it's a very fair point
what i would say is that our intention
was not
to be in a position to lay anyone off
ultimately because of general fund
constraints
we didn't have that flexibility at those
other departments that you mentioned
here with the utility assessment given
that that
is an assessed cost specific to the
regulation of the entity
we felt more comfortable using a
slower transition and
again double accounting for some
positions that will remain
vacant and will not be paid out
rather than forcing um
people out of jobs or to find
alternatives
when there wasn't a compelling reason to
force that issue on day one
representation when your hand was up no
thanks ma'am
so man i'm gonna quote you you just said
you didn't want to ram
anything through this is i've been on
finance this is my sixth term
this is like the most extensive change
in state government
that i've ever seen in house bill 2 in
my six years
madrid well i remember dread but that
wasn't
creating 11 new positions net new
positions
that was an abolishing an important
agency like the puc
that i think has been well recognized
for their work over the years but
why didn't you take this first to say
the
science and technology committee they
deal with puc electrical matters day to
day
i trust their judgment or carol
mcguire's
committee executive departments and
administration
and put the responsibility on the budget
writers if you will
to make a major policy decision such as
this so i i just like to know what
why push this through so quickly through
the you know eight weeks or whatever we
have in finance
where something like this probably
should require a greater review
so i would argue that this has had a
much more extensive review
through the study commission that
chairman bob or former chairman bob
baptist
led last year that specifically
investigated this issue
we had an opportunity to sit with them
that was science and tech wasn't he was
cheering he was
chair of science and tech so i mean
that subcommittee came to a mixed
recommendation to continue studying it
partially because of the pandemic but
ultimately there was
bipartisan broad support for the idea at
some level of conceptual
ness and seeing the opportunity now
to build on the work that was done over
the entirety of last session
we've taken it in a slightly different
direction not to include any parts from
say
des like the air resource division
i think that would be an even heavier
lift um
and i would push back on the idea that
this is more complicated than dread i
think dread was
even though you were splitting things up
that was a much more complex
reorganization
than what we're doing given that we're
merging existing functions of osi into
this single entity
and addressing policy concerns
about potential conflicts of interest
and things of that nature i don't know
that there's
any more complexity with this than what
oplc is currently doing with their
reorganization
and we can talk more about that i'm
happy to do so representative
but i think once we get to the actual
org charts this might become
clearer and simpler conceptually okay
let me ask you another question we have
105 104 positions here your second
bullet point says
four positions are unfunded which of
those four positions where
where would they fit in your chart do we
have
four positions unfunded out of the 82 or
the 12.
out of the 105. yeah but where would i
place them in your chart matt i see what
you're saying
uh they would be between the
osi non-classified and the existing
positions
um okay and i can try to pin exactly
which four live where yeah we can do
that as you go across so i just want an
idea where to look for those yeah
and miss uh excuse me mr chairman woman
if i may um
[Music]
as part of i believe hb2 the new
commissioner uh
at least as we proposed had would have
expressed authority to reduce
vacant positions and just to kind of
keep talking about that the double
counting
if you will some of that may be done
here we need to cut 49 million dollars
we're going to work with you guys on
that because my next thing was going to
be
you will be able to tell us which of the
positions are
currently vacant and not in the process
of being hired for right
correct absolutely and some of those
vacant positions of the 14 that
currently exist
may end up in in the uh you know to have
the department
function properly will need to be funded
but a lot of those folks will be
are not not funded filled uh from
existing other positions and as people
move out of those positions we we would
anticipate and and fully expect that the
commissioner would then
you know unfund and get rid of those i
think you can fully expect they won't
all be here chris
correct by the time you leave here you
can fully expect they won't all be here
the senate always has more money they
get business revenues i
you know what's going on this is a
process that's fluid but we got to meet
our deadlines with our things and
you guys want to get what you want we're
going to try to do the best we can but
we have some financial constraints
absolutely and again i don't think we
would ever
plan for this department to be over a
hundred people
like no matter how many quote unquote
positions exist in the budget system
i don't know that we would ever come
remotely close to
staffing a department like this at that
level
um so that's slide seven
on slide eight uh in
addition to the questions that we
responded to there are just some
technical amendments between
which positions exist in which um
accounting units as well as the
potential to
unfund additional positions we've
identified some of those proactively
and the other thing that i wanted to
mention for the committee
before we get into hb1 and go line by
line the class
27 doit expenses we're engaging
commissioner goulet and his team to
identify the best way
to cost allocate those so the doit
spent expenses as currently in the
budget are correct
just a matter of which accounting units
pay for them
so we're working through doit's very
excited to be consulted
as part of this process um and we would
just want to bring forward a technical
expense neutral amendment um you've got
two days
okay could happen okay two days
i will talk with commissioner goulet
right after this yeah
all right and now to get into the
position charge and if you don't make it
happen here
it's going to the senate okay if you
want it here
two days we will we'll confirm all right
uh now to get into the position charts
and i think this might make it easier
for the committee to understand exactly
what's happening
on slide 11 you see the
additions to bea this is page
595 of the budget book you see these six
positions that currently do planning
functions at osi
when commissioner caswell was here
earlier in the week he mentioned this
accounting two position
it was previously proposed to go to the
department of energy
given the bandwidth constraints of
adding six more staff for
commissioner caswell's shop we would
support the request
to move that to bea um
and i know he has previously talked to
the committee we can figure out
the exact details um depending on what
the
committee views on his party the only
thing we're waiting for in bea right now
matt is
the small business situation which you
and i have conversed about
so we haven't gone forward with his
budget but i have an amendment coming on
that
um the other thing we did was we pushed
the start time of his empty position
it gives us some money but other than
that we're
we're pretty sad okay
on slide 13 you see conservation land
stewardship
this would be page 192 in the budget
book this isn't
100 funded with dedicated funds it says
page 129.
i'm sorry yes page 129. okay i'm paying
attention
chris are you paying attention you
should have caught me first
um these two positions one of them
currently vacant
would be administratively attached to
department administrative services
slide 15 is the division level
organization for the department
i'll start on the top left the office of
the consumer advocate
again there are no changes there it's
administratively attached
the same would go for the adjudicative
commissioners
so those would be the three that rule on
dockets
we'll touch on their staffing needs a
little bit later
you see the office of the commissioner
with
four divisions below them
and then you see the site evaluation
committee which would be
administratively attached as well
slide 16 shows the commissioner's office
this is page 358 of the budget book
two individuals both unclassified
both would require governor and council
approval
neither one of those are filled at this
moment in time of course
because there's not been a nomination
salary for the
commissioner salary for the commissioner
uh again is included in
the responses to our questions or to
your questions
um oh there we go 128 moving to 140 and
deputy 128.
why is the deputy going to be better
paid than the commissioner in fiscal
year 23
that is a a question that i'm working to
resolve with das
i don't i can't specifically explain the
increase
other than that they are at uh specific
labor grades um in this case
labor grade do you have people slotted
for this that you think you're gonna
take
not at this time no the governor i was
saying if you did
but not name that might be a step issue
there
um it it could be a step issue
the the commissioner would be class iii
the deputy is class hh
um we can address why the deputy would
would see that larger jump
but that appears to be anomalous
because we wouldn't we wouldn't find
ourselves in a situation where that
would happen
in reality yeah i would think that the
commissioner would always be paid more
than the deputy yes
a small amount of money but that's just
bizarre
yeah it depends who does the work i
suppose right
the work's been done right here what are
you doing for us
[Music]
okay uh slide
yes representative yeah i have a
question uh where's your microphone oh
there it is
it's been a long day all right
director my you it's a french name sorry
i'm french
okay on slide 15 with the positions for
division level organization you know you
have three positions that are autonomous
from that of the commissioner so these
would be
uh agency levels but there's no
well when you do an organogram there are
lines connecting and there's nothing
connecting here so
they report to themselves or correct and
that's the current structure with the
office of the consumer advocate
and the site evaluation committee
they're administratively attached but
they are autonomous
okay thank you for that clarification
thank you you recall
das talked about that as well and they
have some of those people
yep on slide 17
this is the division of policy and
programs
page 359 of the budget book
you see here it would be led by an
unclassified division director
and then you see the different staff so
i'll go through this
at the first level of detail the
weatherization
program currently exists at osi
would become a part of this division the
sustainable energy division
at the puc would become
part of this division the offshore wind
industry director currently exists at
bea
it has been created but has never been
funded
um that would exist in this division of
policy and programs as well
the fuel assistance program at osi
100 federal would exist here
the nesco manager deals with regional
utility issues in iso new england
currently at the puc
would become here the consumer division
at the puc becomes here
and a program planner from osi that
deals
with
there are no new positions here
everything already exists
and you see that three of these are
currently vacant and how many of them
are unfunded the win director is
unfunded who else is unfunded uh so
there are no there are no unfunded
positions in this accounting unit
so we we are funding the offshore wind
office in this proposal
but he is currently unfunded in this
year's budget
correct yes and who else is currently
unfunded in this year's budget
that'd be the only one in in this
proposal okay
or in this division rather all right
slide 18 is the division of enforcement
you see again an unclassified division
director
the existing audit division at the puc
would exist here the safety division
at the puc would exist here
and the investigations director would
exist here
all of these positions currently exist
at the puc
and what i would note this is an example
where as people move into jobs
in this new department there may be room
to reduce the level of middle management
essentially here because we aren't
looking to force anyone out
you have a division director a safety
director
and an assistant safety director that's
a lot of leadership
for what that division would need to do
so
as people either as vacancies either
become available
or as someone potentially would be
confirmed as a division director
this is an area we would want a future
commissioner to identify
for cost savings yeah i would think
since you
unfunded in other agencies that you
would have unfunded some of those
and just bitten the bullet and said
sorry that job's going away i mean you
did it in other agencies
so in this case with the safety division
safety director
this is 100 federal funds
we chose not to send back the federal
money
and what's the assistant safety director
federal funds
and what's the director of enforcement
it's these going to be general funds
right nope so there are no general
funded positions
positions okay um the division director
would be cost allocated between you
utility assessment and federal funds
and just to stress there are no general
funded positions
at the division level across the board
the only thing that has
general funds would be the site
evaluation committee
no they're not getting any general funds
that's the whole goal of trying to get
rid of those
representative leashman the chair is
um on a trend that i picked up on like
they take a little further
have you identified each one of these
positions
federal other funds uh
you mentioned the conservation i forget
the name of it
fund that would be used for those 2ds
positions could you like
not now but get us which funds are
being allocated like is it the 1.5
million dollars that will be attached to
the ratepayers
so we know what these positions where
the money is coming from
sure and as we go through hb1 i think
that'll be helpful as well at each
accounting unit we'll see those funding
sources
and those be cost allocated but happy to
provide thanks
man it's been very clear from the
legislature that site evaluation
committee
is to be self-funded or ceased to exist
so it is not to be funded with general
funds we've put that into law we've
tried to work with them
i don't think they've been very
responsive to that just thinking they're
going to continually ask for general
funds
but that was clearly the intent of the
legislature
and i'm sorry i think i had misspoke
there because if i go back to
the slide
sorry i can't find my slide five
see that's a view of having them taped
together or stapled together we can find
them
um so you see i i'd have to drill down
in the department of energy but yes so
but none of these positions are general
funded i would just reiterate that
and we we can drill down on the specific
yeah there's
no the intent legislative intent has
always been to be
no general funds into the site
evaluation committee they are
self-funded
generating their own funds yes and that
that continues and i
apologize for that
[Music]
the fiscal committee has given them a
huge amount of money matt and i spoke
about that earlier and i said that was
not the intent
and in both cases while i i like miss
martin saying
well i'm very fiscally conservative the
fact is she came to the fiscal committee
with a gun to our head
i've already spent the money you have to
give it to me because the state had
bills they would have to pay
that's not really the way to do business
you should come and say
i don't have money i would like to do
this will you give me the money
that would have had a different
conversation i think with a different
output
but that wasn't the way the conversation
went and i appreciate she's
works at being fiscally conservative but
spending the money and then saying now
give it to me i've spent it
be like me telling russ i bought the
ferrari figure out how you're going to
pay for it you know that wouldn't go
well my house but it's one of my
fantasies so
um turning to slide 19 you see the
regulatory division again an
unclassified director confirmed by gnc
this accounting unit would be 100
utility assessment funded
and again i would just point to you
probably don't need
on a permanent basis a division director
a bureau director
and an assistant right so this is
probably an opportunity
to find additional savings from the
current proposal
those are filled positions there's the
potential that one of those directors
could move up
into the unclassified the assistant
could backfill them
and you eliminate the assistant but
because it's a governor and council
confirmed position
i can't sit here today and require that
to happen
okay we can just unfund one for you and
then they can work it out
could certainly be one option there
would go
we won't put that burden on you
in the support division and this
division is
designed to be the back office functions
right so you see a division director
unclassified
at the very top row you see the existing
executive director position
and the existing general counsel
position at the puc
those two individuals serve terms at the
pleasure of the commission
the proposal here is for them to fill
out the remainder of their terms
to assist with the transition
and once that term ceases to exist the
position would be abolished
in this division you see the business
office you see positions related to i.t
and again we're working with dennis
goulet and his team
to make sure that we find the right
people for
for these types of roles to bring that
transformational change that we're
hoping to see
federal grants program administrator
uh and other positions you notice that
one two three four five six
seven of these are currently vacant
and i believe two of which are
already unfunded as presented
so manager i would like to inform the
governor's office that um
this this particular slide just is not
correct
it just doesn't line up and it's
virtually unreadable
at some point they just may want to go
back and fix this slide
thank you representative wallace
representation you had a question
thanks madam chair and matt earlier in
one of the slides you said
one position would be abolished i
believe and there'd be
11 new positions so i'm assuming
maybe is that 10 or is that really the
net 11
that would be established so
one of these physicians like the
executive director position the term
ends within fiscal 22 the positions
abolished at the end of fiscal 22
for the general counsel the term ends
within fiscal 23
so the position is abolished in fiscal
so that's where you see that reduction
of one is that abolishment of those two
position titles already in hb2
it is yes all right i believe it's at
the end of hb1
but nonetheless it does exist
michael nancy will you be able to find
that at the end of hb1 force later mary
uh if you're talking to me your sound
just went out
i don't hear anything
can you hear me yes i can hear you bill
i just can't hear the room
can you i can hear the two of you
but not the room
well i'm muted because that's my
computer is that better representative
walls
yes now you're back thank you um
so the question i had was are you
telling me that you're eliminating the
general counsel's position from the puc
is that what i'm to understand the
current
position that is a termed position at
the puc
would no longer exist because the puc is
an entity
would no longer exist there would be
lawyers that support the department of
energy
then those would continue but there
would be no lawyer to support the puc is
that what i'm to understand
i i wouldn't interpret it that way
obviously the puc
will or the adjudicative commissioners
will need
legal support for drafting for research
to review their orders before they're
published those positions exist within
the support division
under the legal director
[Music]
but the puc which would arguably need
its own lawyer or general counsel
whatever title you want to give it
what you what i'm hearing you say is
there will no longer be a lawyer
within the puc to support those
commissioners who themselves do not have
to be lawyers
but yet they are adjudicating matters
representative walls and i think we'll
touch on this when we get to slide 23 as
well
if the committee believes that you know
there needs to be
lawyers specifically allocated into one
of two buckets
i i think there's an opportunity to
explore that
what i would also say is that in
conversations with stakeholders similar
concerns have been raised and as we
prepare a technical amendment
and work through this because again this
is um
you know a proposal that we understand
stakeholders want to weigh in
ultimately we all want to get to a
workable product
um that's something that that certainly
is open to consideration but the
existing position
would no longer have a the position
would
the the role would no longer exist
because the public utilities commission
as an entity
would no longer exist
i understand that the commission goes
away i'm just more worried about under
whatever name
you continue it under that they have the
support they need to issue
legally appropriate decisions we
certainly
share the same concern representative
walls and again we feel comfortable with
how we've put it forward
if the committee wants to put more
lawyers specifically at the puc
in addition to the support they get from
the department of justice
i believe they have two positions
specifically dedicated to them at doj
as well as their staff that we've
established on slide 23 that we'll get
to
i would leave that to the committee to
determine okay
those roles are very different the role
that the ag's office performs and the
roles that the general counsel performs
are very different and maybe even
sometimes conflict with each other
it would be wholly inappropriate to
expect the doj
to fulfill the job that's now being done
by the gc at the puc
i thank you representative walls uh
let's get to slide 23 and we may be able
to clear this up mike and nancy i don't
know if you heard me since we somehow
muted the room at one point
the budget director said that he
believed in hb1
was the abolishment of the two positions
as their terms expired
and i just ask you if you could find
that and confirm that with us at a later
date not right now thank you
yes we can and on slide 20 four of these
positions
are unfunded of those vacancies
so are we on slide 21 map yep so on
slide 21
you see the office of the consumer
advocate we're not making any changes to
personnel
but in order to show you everything we
wanted to
present it here as well
the only change is that it is now
administratively attached to the
department
as opposed to the public utilities
commission so they get back office
support from the department because of
that administrative attachment
they do i believe they do most of their
work in-house
but the potential would continue to
exist
um site evaluation committee is on slide
22.
um there's a vacant administrator
position
and again representative over to your
point you know we invite more
conversation on what the sec should look
like
um going forward might be best done
outside of the budget but but happy to
to you know entertain those
conversations be happy to unfunded here
and then you guys can come up with a way
to do it
i i don't know if i would go that far
given if it's general funds
i'm going to i've we've spoken about
that before
okay we can we can connect on that
and then lastly the adjudicative
commissioner so and representative walls
i think this might
away some of your concerns you see the
three
adjudicative commissioners at the top
you see
five classified staffers including a
utility analyst ford that's currently
vacant unfunded
this positions are erroneous we in a
technical amendment would propose to
abolish this position which position is
that the utility
the vacant unfunded position ah
okay thank you
um they do have legal research
assistance they do have an attorney
and they have sick staff that fill that
advisory capacity
uh representative leitchman to your
point that help them decide
and rule and write their orders but
these individuals do not appear in the
hearing room
right so they're on the commissioner's
side of the table they're never
appearing before the commission to
present facts or establish the record
their role is uh strictly support and
and not advocacy
and that's the advocacy is left to the
division of regulatory
uh support
well but i do want to be clear though
that we want to establish a bright red
line
where you don't have someone that is
appearing in a hearing room
to present a case then also be able to
advise
that commission how they should rule
right into your point looking at either
federal board to the courts
you don't see an a defense attorney
present a case and then get to walk out
back with the judge and help him write
his opinion
do you have a follow-up representative
representation yeah man i'm sure
um i've been before federal boards and
courts before and that's just not true
but defense attorneys do in fact not to
be argumentative
do go back and sit with the judge when
the public's not present
so that's not quite true i think we'd
both agree there's
it would be better to have a scenario
where that doesn't happen
given ex parte rules and also just a
fundamental fairness issue
with these matters represent walls you
have another question
i do thank you madam chair um i'm
concerned by the size of the staff
that's being allocated to the
adjudicative commissioners
division and it seems to me that that's
a effectively a much smaller
level of support than the current
commissioners get
and i'm concerned that this is really
not enough staff for them to do their
jobs
as they are currently able to do it and
and i'm just i'm
very concerned about what we're doing
here in terms of pulling so much out of
the puc and and separating them from
these people
i think there's perhaps more interaction
than we think
so i guess i'm wondering how the
assessment was done
as to how small the staff
would be at the adjudicated
commissioners division
um compared to the kind of support they
have now like who did that assessment
so our office you know worked through
the
study commission that was done last year
to identify
what those roles would look like you
know we've had conversations
to identify potential areas
if it's the commission's prerogative to
move more
staff into this accounting unit and out
of the support division
or out of the regulatory division
i think we're open to working with the
committee to figure out
what those numbers are but again these
positions are purely designed
to help advise the commissioners on
their ruling these are not people that
are compiling evidence
or building the record so for what this
role and function would be and given
that the commissioners are no longer an
agency head
right you have a department of energy
they're not overseeing the day-to-day
operations
they're cordoned off allowed to sit in
that adjudicative capacity
we felt that this was an appropriate
staff given what their new function
would be
at the end of this transition their
current role is much larger
most of that now exists at the
department level which is why
we put a commensurate amount of staff
directly with them
and that current study and then that
study that was done in science and
technology under chairman
backus they recommended pulling them out
and taking some of those administrative
functions away from them so they could
concentrate on this
there were a number of proposals and the
committee never endorsed a specific plan
but we did look at other states right so
connecticut for example
has their des and their public utilities
commission
essentially combined that was one
option that we explored we determined it
was not the best path forward for the
state of new hampshire
and this was a alternative to again
address those three policy concerns we
mentioned up front
establish a line of demarcation between
advisory and technical to
make sure that all these positions are
governor and council confirmed
to boost accountability and third
to ensure that these efforts are unified
under a single department
as it relates to energy okay so
that concludes your powerpoint where
is your preference to go next matt um
i guess just to talk uh
i suppose about the questions
representative over that you've asked of
others
third document we've looked at the
letter we've looked at the powerpoint
we're going to look at the questions and
then we'll look at the budgets
yes uh so division one
i'm sorry not division one we're in
division one yes you are in division one
congratulations welcome
number one either way um
so in this budget there is accounted for
moving expenses
and new it costs um
i know the question is written to
allocate those all to
specific positions i can do that as a
follow-up
what you see here is just salary and
benefits
mainly because the moving costs and the
new it costs for
setup and startup were not specifically
allocated
again we worked with doit we worked with
das to identify what those costs would
be
but in not in all cases were
specifically assigned to a position
so you're probably going to end up with
a budget that does not have
class 39 class 27 assigned appropriately
current state law allows an agency
to come to fiscal with their transfer
and with the establishment of
classes so if you like don't get your
telecommunications worked out for six
months or something
there's a way to come to fiscal and then
have those budget adjustments made
and i would concentrate your time we're
most needed and not trying to get that
by deadlines
i appreciate that chairwoman and again
duits confirm that the total dollars
we're spending
are in the ballpark so you've got them
in one bucket you can move them around
when you need to by
having the agency come to fiscal correct
um so you see the new positions their
source of fund is also delineated here
in this chart
for the commissioner it would be utility
assessment and federal funds
cost allocated through an indirect uh
or intra-agency transfer of those funds
the same for the deputy the division
directors
depending on which division they're in
are either utility assessment
or a combination of utility assessment
federal funds and dedicated funds
and then finally the six utility
analysts that directly support the
commission
our advisory staff to the commissioners
and they're 100
funded by the utility assessment
the two positions we're eliminating at
the outset
are delineated here
at the end of their current term and to
chris
chris's point the commissioner does have
expressed authority
to further reduce positions during the
biennium as they become vacant
and that would be our expectation of
this new commissioner to take
that's found in some section in hb2 yes
i
uh as we go through it i can point that
out
there's about 40 pages of hb2 yeah i
don't have all of them
uh memorized just yet but we'll we'll
get there yeah
they put me to sleep um
the answer to four was yes five was not
applicable
um and this point with hb2 we cast
the broadest net we could on all the
energy statutes that
could potentially be affected in
stakeholder conversation it's become
apparent that some statutes have been on
the books since the 1950s
and have never been used so whether or
not we need to reintroduce them
or repeal them exactly so there may be
additional amendments to hb2 as we work
with stakeholders
probably not something that will be done
in two days but certainly during the
senate phase
none of that will move the numbers in
hb1 at all
no and if you find those
reasons can you just keep me on the
mailing list even though it's come out
because
it does come back to a committee
conference it helps if we understand
what's going on
i'm going to try to get to the senate as
much as i can but
we'll have some house business too
understandable
um and then the remainder of this
document
is just again the class 27 conversation
that we've engaged doit with
um and then a series of position changes
um either abolishing positions that are
currently in hb1
um or moving positions between
accounting units
either for a technical reason or in one
instance a position moved
in one fiscal year but not the next we
would just want to align that
for both fiscal years
and happy to talk more about these as we
go through the budget
okay where do you want to go next
all right so i would say to hb1 if you
want to do that what's the page number
one second here i have it marked of
course you do
358 i'm surprised you hadn't memorized
that matt
well i would i would actually start on
which is in the department of
administrative services we did that one
we're you're good
okay you're good
which brings us to 359. yep
um i'm sorry yes 358 actually is where
it begins
so the office of the commissioner you'll
notice that these
are the expenses for two positions
including class 39
so we have accounted for some of that
all of the funds in this accounting unit
are from agency indirect cost recoveries
the idea is to leverage each funding
source
in a proportional way so a federal grant
would pay a proportional share
of the commissioner's salary similar to
the way it's done at hhs similar the way
that it's done
at other departments that have a variety
of funding streams
you notice here that because this is a
new division there was no budget
tied directly to this for 20 and 21.
yeah i'm actually trying to figure out
how you're going to pay these people
first of july
what do you mean representative ober
this won't exist
so the the commission is
the reorganization is effective
september 1st
so you have osi money in the budget
so this is going to be a a technical
conversation
on how the transition occurs um
there may need to be one-sixth of a year
allocated to the existing structure
while individuals are confirmed for gnc
because obviously this new department
couldn't be stood up on july 1st that's
just what i said
yeah i was wondering how you were going
to pay these people that is something
that has also come up
during our stakeholder conversations yes
um
we you wouldn't see a net increase in
funds you would just see
a uh you would see
osi and the puc continue and exist for
those
two transitional months is what we would
need to do
via an amendment to hb1
alternatively and this wouldn't be our
preference
you could have this take effect
in fiscal year 23 only
and fund the existing structure for a
full year
but again that the idea being that there
is a phase
you're aware of the problem i mean i can
see the problem when you flip up that
page
so again this this won't be an increase
in
in funding you won't have that fixed in
two two days either so
just keep me on the mailing list for
what you do
so when it comes back for the committee
of the conference we have some idea
what's
in the division one what's been going on
thank you
and we'll just proceed as though we were
going to ignore that lovely little
glitch
we'll come back to it in accounting in
you see policy and programs
another note that i would make between
the budget that you see in 20 and 21
because the pucs current structure was
self-contained
within a single accounting unit the
entire agency
we did have to break out those different
funding streams to try to give it
some semblance of history so you'll
notice the
the increase is almost double in this
particular accounting unit
i would attribute that just to a quirk
of how
we pulled or disaggregated if you will
the prior puc structure which was all
within a single accounting unit it would
really be great if you could work out
and get rid of all the double budgeting
before
it inflates the budget in a way
shouldn't be inflated
and when you inflate the budget in a way
that shouldn't be inflated
then it's easy to say the next budget
year well the budget only went up two
percent
and people forget that uh yeah but four
percent of that budget was double
counted it should have been backed out
so
anything you can do to get rid of that
would be very helpful
absolutely and we can certainly explore
ways with das
to maybe have a position um
that week i think they can help you they
have to do some of that with doit
now so
thank you
all right so i've turned to page 360 and
so far i see you're using either agency
income
or federal funds which means you aren't
really using
general funds which is what we
concentrate on
correct a variety of reasons um
362 is agency income
as is 363.
[Music]
and while we are here actually uh the
issue is pointing out with the reggie
dollars the increase in auction proceeds
you see that and i apologize that i
missed this this is on page 359
class line 73 and i apologize to go back
madam chairwoman it's okay you'll notice
it's appropriated at 20.8 million in
each year
yep you notice there's nothing in
20 and 21 the 20 and 21 appropriation
is found on page 361 class line 73
just the same at 16.5
and 12.7 million okay
and again this is just a matter of
history trying to
translate across different accounting
units
so matt where's the first page that we
see general fund usage
in this new agency
would be page 367
i'm sorry 366 which is within
the division of administrative support
and that is 66 000
yep and 69 000.
i would have to report back on exactly
which class line that's attributable to
that's all right just kind of looking
at what you've got here
okay 369 starts the site evaluation
committee
but they have general fund dollars and
that's not what we want
for them so you see the current
20 and 21 at 254 and 286.
their general fund dollars have been
reduced yeah and they've got a million
more
as i said it was she works very hard to
keep it
fiscally conservative but when you come
and you say well you got to pay these
because i spent the money you leave the
state in a hole and even if we don't
like the way she spent the money
we don't have an opportunity to say no
that's not something we want done
and man i'm sure you'll see the footnote
allowing them to come to fiscal to get
more fun yeah i know that's going away
and would just need to think about how
those assessment dollars for the
applicants that they would be able to
fund
the operation sufficient they can fund
those they can't come to fiscal and ask
for more money
that so that would not be coming to
fiscal to ask for more money what
what representative leishma is talking
about is what has happened
she's come and said i don't have
assessment dollars so now i want
the general court to give me another
couple hundred couple i think we've
given her a couple million this year
and always after the fact so no that's
got to go away and somehow
i'm going to leave that to you i've made
some suggestions to you about what i
think
they could do instead i'm not sure
that having a committee meet to see if
somebody is following the rules
as opposed to saying to des well they've
got these permits make sure they're
following the rules for the permits is
the better way to go i mean i think
some of that work is duplicative of some
of the great work that des
does for us and i think we need to be
careful about paying for duplicative
work
and i i appreciated those conversations
chairwoman is
chairwoman martin from the puc on by
chance i don't know it doesn't matter
what's happened has happened this is not
going to continue to happen that's where
we're going is going forward
i'm not faulting her for what she did
i'm saying going forward that's not
going to happen
and just what i would say is the oppo
the
alternative would be to increase those
filing fees for new projects well then
you guys have to work that out
okay i would i would just say that
that's the
only other source of money well she
didn't use the filing fees
for projects she needed the money
because she was having hearings after
the fact
to see if they were complying with what
the sec had already ruled and the
permits they had gotten
so she'd already spent the money of the
filing fees
and was doing that and then she said
well i have some other things where we
can review and track
those are the items you need to think
about that's not necessarily a filing
fee that's a monitoring fee
and if des has gone and is doing
monitoring of all the permits that go
out and the wastewater and all that
other
they already have a staff to do that
that we're paying for
we shouldn't be having a committee
duplicate that
i i agree with you i just want to
identify and i believe there's a bill
we're going to get rid of this footnote
and i believe there's a bill that is
currently
in finance it might even be this
division or might be on the senate side
that's proposing to reduce these fees in
some instances
that i don't think we have that and that
would be in ways and means they deal
with fees
right so i believe it is already gone
out of the first committee but i'd
have to report back on that it may be
ways and means
i do have my bill numbers here i have
all the bills here that we have in
finance
um and i don't think we have one of
those
it mostly got deaths benefits we've got
repaying fines right to know
ombudsman payment of bail commissioners
and more death benefits madam chairman i
believe
the bill was in ways you were correct
yeah my apologies
we spend they collect
that's what my husband's doing that's
why he always tells me just cut your
spending money
what do you mean you need more money for
the budget just cut your spending
all right we'll address that uh
chairwoman
on page 371 you see the adjudicative
commissioners
again here a utility assessment would be
their funding source
uh which brings us down to 372 which is
the end
and again just want to stress that the
totals
on this page especially when it comes to
the position count
the big change that osi non-classified
positions are
now they now appear in this line because
we've
reclassified them and then the
total increase in other funds
is by and large tied to the regional
greenhouse gas
initiative auction which is projected to
yield more money
for ratepayer rebates and that explains
the jump
along with the increase in federal funds
that we're projecting to receive
for 22 and 23. the intention is not to
increase the headcount of this
department
the intention is not to create permanent
increases in the utility assessment
and again there are just some
transitional pains that would go through
something like this but we do believe
that coming out on the other side
once that transition occurs we'll have
better outcomes for ratepayers
a more efficient department and also
resolve some of those long-standing
policy concerns that several people have
raised on a bipartisan basis
all right so we've still got hb2 yes
[Music]
on hb2 and these sections
begin on page 85
and go forever and go forever but the
reason we've done that again is that we
casted
the broadest net that we could to make
sure that everything was in one spot and
if there are functions that no longer
are applicable
that exist in current law this will be
an opportunity
to work with stakeholders
and eliminate those outdated statutes
our office has already begun that
process
meeting with stakeholders soliciting
feedback
on what an amendment to hb2
that doesn't impact the financials would
look like
those conversations are ongoing and
stakeholders i would advise you at this
point to write the smallest
amendments it is better to have
10 separate amendments that says repeal
rsa xyz
than to rewrite this because if you get
to the committee of conference
and you've got as many pages as you've
got here matt
it is very likely you would lose your
whole department because we're just
so pressed for time at that time
as opposed to a single consolidated
amendment yeah don't do that
okay do make it as simple as possible
so that as much as as we approve in both
the house and the
senate stands without us having to go
through and
go page by page to nitpick so please
i'd rather see 20 small amendments
repeal rsa 8
i don't know what they're going to be
then to make
wholesale changes here okay i appreciate
that
representative i mean it it's a
nightmare when you've got five or six
days
to try to marry what you thought i mean
you know here's here's basically what
happens the house is going to vote this
amendment
it's like sending a kid to college and
then the kid comes back from college
two years later with purple hair
you're the parent you're not happy so
that's what happens at the committee
conference phase so make it as
simple as possible no purple hair please
we have simple minds it gets late at
night we get cranky by 11 o'clock at
night
so most of this is currently contained
in rsa 363
which is the establishment of the public
utilities commission it's their charter
because the puc is going away that
statute as well as some others that
are tied to osi are now consolidated in
rsa12 dash p that's what you see here in
hb2
um commissioner i don't know i'm sorry
commissioner i'm reading commissioner
chairwoman i don't know unless you want
the job commission
sherwin
exactly why would i take a job paying
less money i mean you know you're right
i'm from finance i'll take more money
chairman is your preference to go line
by line section by section what's the
the best way to
do something this large oh it's horrible
line by line is pretty tough when we've
got this many lines
if we can in general maybe
what we're doing we can see the
definitions i'm on page 86
obviously i've read the purpose i've
read through this two or three times so
this is not new reading for us we've all
had it we've all been working on it
this is
the hard thing it is hard thing it is
with this man
is normally we see new language bolded
old language and regular type and this
is all
pretty much all in regular type i won't
say all of it because i'm sure if i did
there'd be a
thing in here that was new but this is
all
basically brand new language
has some bolding yes so
you are you start at the bottom of page
and you run through i think a bunch of
positions about
getting appointed how to be appointed
going to
which is pretty boilerplate language if
you might
for as you said all the positions that
go to gnc now
is there anything in those sections that
is
strange or only this one because when i
read that i thought that looked
fairly every agency does that it is
straightforward the only thing i would
touch on are the initial terms
that phase in so that once this is up
and running
one division director will come up each
year
right so we're doing staggered four-year
terms that's probably better you'll have
some continuity
correct that's the only thing of note
that i would say
page 87 line 28 the duties of the
commissioner
are pretty standard i would say
um nothing unique to this agency
compared to others
from there on page 88 the division of
administration
and other divisions are established
on page 89 line 4 the state energy
strategy
which is currently a function of the
office of strategic initiatives
in rsa4e becomes a function of the
department of energy
so are you deleting rsa4e
yes that is repealed i believe at the
end of the energy
okay provisions all right so you have
gotten some of that cleanup
yes uh just one note on the state energy
strategy section uh initially that was
something that was
uh introduced in 2014 with a renewal
after three years
this does update that to have a new
state energy strategy for 2021
is that wise
yes if you don't think you're going to
have everybody through
gnc until in september you're only going
to give them a few months to do a whole
strategy
i'm wondering if that date
is a little premature given the fact
you're reorgan too
i'm sure that that you know 2022 could
be something they worked on i do know
that the office of strategic initiatives
in their current function of having to
review it every three years uh
has started to look at that process so
they will probably have
some lead into all right as you can hear
i'm just concerned about the length of
time of the reorgan then
trying to have people meet a deadline
that might be unreasonable
madam chair representative policeman i
really like your idea of trying to
push this a little ahead just going
through my notes when i read through
this
there were so many references still to
the public utilities commission
like i direct you to page like 103 line
17 the chairman of the public utilities
commission
shell obviously above that they crossed
out the public utilities commission but
in roman numeral four they left it you
go to page 104
line 11 the public utilities commission
and the department of energy which i
thought we were eliminating the public
utilities commission so
there's all sorts of references through
again you go
down to line 20 i underlined it same
thing the chairman of the public
utilities commission comma the
commissioner
of the department of energy so it looks
like the public utilities commission is
still in existence so
those are the things that give me a
little pause because this
division especially in the finance
committee i've always looked
at a good product coming out of here and
when i find mistakes like this this
isn't a good product
thank you i appreciate that
representative leishman and i agree
there are some
technical drafting changes that need to
be made you know those are on my list as
well
in two days i apologize we didn't catch
those during the governor's phase
we shouldn't have to catch it and we've
caught them ourselves as well so we'll
and the other thing is that in some
instances just a matter of changing it
from public utilities commission to
the adjudicative commissioners that
would continue to exist so again
those issues are just references so so
matt we're going to challenge you
you're coming back tuesday morning
with dj yes to go over family leave
bring the fixed amendment for that with
you
we'll do representative okay
certainly because this to me it looks
like a growth in government
which has never been a big fan of mine
as far as growing government but
could you give us a comparison between
the expense or cost of the puc
and the expense and cost of the osi
so we could see the comparison you've
got new positions but it costs us so
much for these two agencies now
what is the department of energy going
to cost because
i'm seeing numbers here quickly
reviewing it this is going to cost us a
little more money maybe not all in
general funds as you pointed out
but somebody's going to have to pay for
these costs
i i agree and it's on the very last page
of the budget that we just reviewed that
pertains to this
that's 10 million dollars and and the
explanation i gave just a few minutes
ago
was that 8 million each year is tied to
the regional greenhouse gas
emissions or inventory auction
that is projected to yield more money
that is a direct pass through to
ratepayers
so it's an increase in grants but that's
not
anything that the state has control of
it's something we get for participating
in the program
and we rebate back to that fluctuates a
lot
it does but our expenses are directly
proportional to our revenues
so that's the vast majority of any
increase you see in the budget book
the other thing that you see is an
increase in federal funding
for weatherization and lie heap as a
result of recent federal bills
and the consolidated appropriations act
that we saw pass in december
and there is a as i mentioned before a
1.5 million dollar increase in utility
assessment
that is mainly driven by double
accounting for some positions
as part of the transition our intention
is not to increase head count
it is not to increase the draw on the
utility assessment
and i i would just use those three
things to explain
why it looks like there's a much larger
increase
than we would ever support if those were
ongoing fixed costs for a new department
we wouldn't come forward with a proposal
to increase the department by 18
there's absolutely no need to go down
that path
but there are some anomalies that have
distorted what that bottom line
total looks like i'm pretty simple i
just like to see simple
no answers and i can strip out those
anomalies if you'd like and get it back
to that
just what we're seeing in that utility
assessment during the transition
and i'm happy to provide that to the
committee thanks madam chair for
allowing me to
continue okay page 105. madam chair i do
have my hand
up yes i know wait a moment this is the
same thing it's a follow-up to
okay representative leitchman
105 site evaluation committee
you have the commissioner of the puc on
there
as well as adding the commissioner of
the department of energy
i think you should make that nine
members commissioner of department of
energy
or an adjudicative member or of this
and you don't want a committee of ten
people then you vote five to five this
is bad
and get rid of that one line but put him
on
as you can see what was done with e
where's one of several people can come
that allows that to happen and when
you're doing your amendment
let's fix that and i'd agree and given
that osi
currently does not have a seat i don't
know that you would need
to increase the head count so right stay
at nine and and we need to
it says the commission or the puc or
something okay
commissioners the commissioners of the
public utilities
commission the chairperson which shall
be the chairperson of the committee
well that committee goes away mrs martin
will no longer be the chairperson of
that committee because it's called
something else
so you need to work that out yeah and it
really should be annoying
and we will fix those cascading
references yeah i just want to make sure
that got in because it piggybacked on
what peter was saying he and i had
picked up on some of the same things
representative walsh you have your hand
up for a question thank you for waiting
i do thank you so much so i'm wondering
i'm sure the word
i'm using the wrong word but just as we
sometimes do a crosswalk on positions
i'm wondering if we can set up a
complete chart of dollar for dollar
where the money is coming from and where
it's going
so that we can see how much what the how
much reggie's being increased where it's
going how much is
more the additional utility assessment
and
how much of this federal money might be
a one-time thing
i'm concerned that some of the federal
money is not necessarily going to be
ongoing
that we might set up this department
based on one-time federal monies and
then find that we have to
come up with that money in future
budgets so there's an interesting thing
with federal money
it says if the federal funding money
goes away
you will not use general fund dollars so
what you would see in future budgets is
things would be cut if that money goes
away
represent walls i mean that's that's a
good thing to ask but that is the
standard practice and standard language
in the state with those grants
and especially given that the federal
dollars in this
instance are weatherization and the
low-income
heating uh low fuel assistance for low
income individuals in new hampshire
um low income home energy assistance
and that varies every year we see
different amounts in there correct and
osi
pays out what they receive and not more
and to the extent that those fluctuate
you would there would be no change in
our
status or our standard operating
procedure for those grants
mike and nancy you heard mary best
requested about a crosswalk showing
where they came from in the monies
can one one or both of you work with the
governor's budget director to get that
done and have it for us by tuesday
yes we can try to do that i've started
something that i can share with them
okay thank you all right representative
waltz we'll try to get that for you by
tuesday
thank you do you have a follow-up i do
not that was that that's really what i
was looking for
i i just want to follow the money yep
i got you we'll see if we can get that
done by tuesday
all right matt continue wherever you are
madam chair if i may i just wanted to
clarify one thing that uh representative
leashman had brought up
related to many of the references here
uh because
the the adjudicative commissioners will
retain the name the public utilities
commission
in a lot of cases uh the references that
remain are not
mistakes they're there because that
group of adjudicative commissioners
will need to fill a role for whatever it
may be so they weren't drafting errors
so much as
decisions that that group of
adjudicative commissioners should still
remain involved we we don't disagree
that they should be a
involved what we're talking about is the
fact that you are actually replacing
them and giving them a new title
and we had this issue with dread you
guys
weren't here then but nathan white at
lba
had to go through i can't tell you how
many pages and verify the language
across all of the things
equally peter and i were sitting on the
committee at that time it was
a huge overhaul so it's it's just
something that we need to
correct and make right
and we're happy to do that we understand
it you're going to have it but
it's got to be right uh i'll go to page
90 from there
the office of offshore wind industry now
is that new
yes this was passed it was senate bill
last session that was bundled into house
bill 1245
that died that was signed into law there
was no appropriation
it was signed in the law yes
12 45 yeah so there exists this office
it's not funded
currently
this was a senator waters bill from last
but that never came to the house really
never had a public hearing
uh correct and why is this in here if it
exists in state law
because we are repealing rsa 363
as well as some others what and unifying
this
what's that number i'm on the repeal
section now read me the rsa again
363 and this
this particular item might be in another
statute i i don't know exactly where
this was codified it might be 374
h but i i would check the reference for
you
yeah i don't see that here at the
in your repeals
okay you i need that by tuesday okay
okay let's go on you see the additional
divisions again that's boilerplate
language
page 91 talks about natural gas and the
authority that would exist
with the commission and that was
existing law already that you moved
right
yes almost none of this is new language
if anything i i couldn't point to a
piece of new language that's not
currently on the books
again this is really translating from
one structure of government to another
um on page 92 line three this is a
statute
that was introduced in the 50s amended
in 79
and no one can point to a time in which
it was
used um this might be an opportunity
just to repeal it as well
we're working with stakeholders to
identify if there's a compelling reason
to keep it on the books or not so line 3
through 12
yes
and again we'll continue those
conversations
uh at the bottom of 92 you see the
governor's scholarship program
this is a program that used to exist at
osi osi is going away
so it renames the chapter title
to account for that that's now in
treasury
yeah uh 194
or page 93 top page three is just the
organizational structure the executive
branch
you see the positions that we've created
here
page 94 moves the division of planning
to the department of business and
economic affairs
the subsequent section details existing
authority that the division of planning
has at osi
that they would continue to have at the
department of business and economic
affairs
that continues on page 95 as well
into page 96.
continuing forward to 97 still existing
authorities that division of planning
has
section 200 is the name of the
department
which replaces osi with department of
energy in a series of statutes
line 8 on page 98 changes a reference
this is related to the state energy
strategy that's where it is
back up to wherever you want we'll go
i'm not quite familiar with the policies
and plans it's in the bottom of page 95
line 34 and going over to 96
there are a number of things listed
which are done by
other departments in the state so
is that existing language there now that
you're just moving over or is this
creating
more oversight of all these
a through j which again
some of them have already are handled by
other agencies like water resources or
solid waste
i'll verify the existing rsa that this
comes from
but it is existing language okay thanks
thanks madam chair i think we did that
piece
when osi was created and planning moved
into osi
man i think you've got serious problem
on page 99
section 207 really cannot say public
utilities commission quorum because
now your new adjudicators won't have a
quorum
so be sure you try when you fix that
fix that i'm sorry i'm not following
and we start you've got in 206
207 208
your specified public utilities
commission
since that's actually going away you
want to be sure your your new
adjudicative division
has got a quorum has got this has got
that
and what i would say and again this is
something that will cascade through
on section 204 you see puc
remains a defined term
in the statute
to articulate that we are changing this
i would agree
it should be renamed to the adjudicative
commissioners
and cascade through yeah but that's why
it appears the way that it does
throughout but i i do agree with the
representative leashman and yourself
that we should clarify
that it's not the existing entity it is
the new entity right someday you and i
won't be sitting here it needs to be
clear
absolutely
and somebody ought to be able to do a
control f
find all these or even ctrl r and
replace it with this phrase and pop it
in
i mean that's computers are great at
things like that
represent walls yeah i have a concern i
just want to raise
um it looks like that um 363-1
is making the chair of the commissioner
report directly to the governor
does matt mean the governor could
influence the commission which is
supposed to be independent
that's my concern with the way this is
drafted
i'm sorry representative walls which is
the governor on
on page 99 yeah i got it what line
number
four lines at the beginning so it's 363
one commission term in there doesn't it
talk about
[Music]
um
i don't see it saying one reports to the
governor that's what i'm missing
all right maybe i've got my notes wrong
um
try what about don on line
i don't know let me get back to my notes
and i'll come back to this okay
all right
all right please continue matt she's
gonna look i don't know i didn't see
that so
we don't all see everything so if she
finds it we'll go back to it
and the other thing representative ober
that we might do
through this amendment is consolidate
the repeals
into a single series of consecutive
sections
easier to deal with for sure yeah but
again you
got to get this done by tuesday so my
thought is
what can you do to get it done by
tuesday morning
and you gotta make that decision i can't
do it for you
time is a finite resource yes it is
on page 100 you see the repeal of the
sections that directly relate to those
positions that would no longer exist
yep the office the consumer advocate all
we're changing here is its
administrative attachment
to the department
that continues on page 101 yeah
just a series of reference changes yeah
and 102.
and 103.
continuing to 104. yep
we've noted the concern on the site
evaluation committee membership on 105.
a lot of the rest of this is that
reference
change into department of energy
even through page 116 we're
doing primarily reference changes and
that continues even when i turn to 117.
not sure we have do we have anything
substantive after that
with the change other than the reference
change
to department of energy uh on page 118
and into the beginning of 119
um is the contracting authority
reducing it to the level set by governor
and council oh the ten
ten thousand dollars
and again i think this is institute more
uh
standard procedure for this new entity
that every other agency and state
government has to go
through
so
this
yeah this goes away this this is exactly
what we had in dread only
we were splitting into two different
agencies so you had to figure out which
agency went to one
which one went to the other one and we
had page after page after page of this
reference change like you're saying
where it says now department of energy
that goes into state law and that
disappears and never comes back
represent walls your hand is up yeah i
went back
and i figured out what my concern was
and so if we can go back to page 99
for a moment i will explain it
if you go to page 99 and look at 9
7. line 7 says the chair of the
commission shall have the powers and
duty set forth in rsa 21 g9
21 g9 is what says that the commissioner
should report directly to the governor
so by incorporating that reference
that's where that comes from and that's
where my concern came from
and that's why it took me a few minutes
was to go back and figure out exactly
what it was is that
i knew there was an issue but to go
figure it out took a couple of minutes
but that's the reference that becomes
problematic
let me respond after this hearing just
to go through
21 g9 and determine if this is something
that only should apply to the department
agency head as opposed to the uh chair
of the commission but i'll report back
to you on that representative walls
it's lovely you're coming back on
tuesday yes
thank you sir
[Music]
okay man i'm trying to get through to
the end of the hb2 sections
to see if we have anything else
substantive
other than reference changes
and i'm on page 134 and i still don't
see much
the one concern that has been raised by
stakeholders is in page 136
relative to utility restructuring
um that is something this section
becomes
an acronis to the current state of
affairs because
utility restructuring has happened so
directing this new department to start a
proceeding
which again is existing language um
this doesn't make a ton of sense so
again this is a product of casting a
wide net
copying everything out of one part of
the law into a new part of the law
but we would not intend to begin a new
restructuring utility restructuring
as a result of this becoming law
people are zooming in this is like
watching paint dry because we're
flipping pages
our zoom audience is bigger than it's
been so they must like watching paint
drawing
are we gonna hold three people
chairwoman no we have 16.
wow
so just one further representation
so matt i assume when you say
stakeholders i hope you're talking to
chairman bose of science and technology
and
getting his comments and suggestions he
was asked to look at this just so you
know
and we've had conversations with him
we've had conversations
um you know with outside stakeholders as
well
um whether it be you know regional
groups that deal with energy issues
utilities
the office of the consumer advocate
to wanting to make sure that a we get
this right and it is workable
directionally there's a lot of broad
bipartisan support for this idea
chairman backus of course someone that
spearheaded this idea
while he was still in the legislature um
and again we we see there are three
fundamental policy principles that i've
identified previously i won't go back
over them
but this is something that a lot of
people have been talking about
and we're excited to now have a vehicle
uh to do this
michael bells was asked two weeks ago to
look at this he's not had
gotten back with any concerns
another area is on page 149 the
multi-use energy data platform
this is something that is ongoing our
intention would not
be to require that process to restart as
a result of this
that's another section that we've heard
and i think the concern specifically is
on page 150 lines 9 and 10 to initiate a
rule making
as opposed to open a docket and that's
just a tren
again an anachronous uh scenario of
where current law says and what the
process has been
um well again just want to make sure
that there's a seamless transition there
so they've been making rules and not
opening
dockets they've there's currently an
adjudicated proceeding
that's open at the commission we would
want that to continue to be
the venue for conversation okay so that
again just a a matter of timing on that
madam chair yes mr hatch
i made to that end um when you say
you're starting your rulemaking process
exactly what do you mean by that are
they having
notified public hearings or is it
informal
to what extent are they doing that and
that's
quite important i would defer to
um either the parties to that docket or
the
puc to the extent they can speak about
an ongoing proceeding
i'm not familiar with the granular
details of where that proceeding is
so this is not changing any of the rules
or procedures
of the established puc is that what
you're saying
that's that was my point that one that's
what i was trying to fish out
yeah okay i think we have a wrong term
that's fine thank you that's okay
i think we got it worked out mr hatch
thank you that is the end of
the hb2 sections
can i torture you for another
the minute getting hot chairwoman i know
you want to make kristen in for a while
[Laughter]
i want to turn to page 16 in the budget
this is the hb1 yeah yeah this is the
office of the governor and i didn't
actually after i looked through here
we have already approved the governor's
council on disability
uh chuck sayo came out and did a great
job
at the bottom of page 16. you have the
office of the governor
and one can see that general fund usage
has gone down and then if you turn
to page 15
you also have general funds and you can
see the governor was
pretty much as harsh on himself as he
was other agencies general funds go down
in 23 we have the issue of the
extra pay period so we've seen general
fund usage go up there
but i really didn't see anything unusual
or
added in the executive branch
budget whatsoever and as i said we went
through
the gcd and we approved that budget
previously
but am i correct that you just basically
are flat funded
yes we applied that same starting point
for
our office the same way we did for every
other department in state government
and i'll also use this opportunity on
page 16 to look at the total
number of positions that exist in the
governor's office
according to the budget book is one
um of course and this speaks to why osi
is unique as well
there are more than there's more than
one position in the guys oh obviously
you guys are here and you're in there i
mean we see that all the time sometimes
you forget it
it shows up more when you're doing
something like you are with the
department of energy
and because we don't think about it a
whole lot i mean
dj's there the two of you are there i
don't know who else is there but there's
a whole
plethora of staff sitting there not just
one person yes
but we didn't reorganize you yes i will
say dj is now
uh at the end of the day he's moved yes
yes he has okay
insurance yes
um representative walsh you have your
hand up i
do um so i'm going through this
and it appears that they're including in
here a section that has been
repealed in law um
so i think let me make sure i've got the
page right
um yeah if you go to page 126.
age 126 is this hb2
this is hb2 i believe she's looking at
it is correct
and you go to the bottom of the page
where it starts with 374.22
what line is that 33. 33
we're looking there and the subsequent
sections in there
i think that may have been repealed in
2012.
um so i think that deserves some
looking at i'm sorry i'm just catching
up here page 126.
page 126 matt uh in hb2
line 33 correct
well in case you haven't gathered matt
we're not taking any action on this this
afternoon because
you're coming back with lots of
questions so yes
uh line 33 shared we're looking at
that section has been repealed and she
would like you to look at it
and that goes through page 127
line 27 page 127 line 20
line 16. so it goes it starts on 126
flips over to 127.
i will review that section as well
reporting back on tuesday yes
okay so to be clear as i say it wasn't
all repealed but most of it was and i
think
but parts that are included in here are
part of the parts that were repealed
so i think it deserves a really careful
look because
it seems silly to be including repealed
laws in this
and i will i'll compare that to the
existing law
and see what was the the root cause of
that um
and representative walls was is this a
potential situation where chapter law
might say one thing
or do you feel that the language in the
rsa as it exists today
lba might be able to help you with that
matt that would be where i would go to
essex
i'm just i guess my concern is i don't
know where we would have found repealed
language to include
so i just want to make sure we can track
that micro nancy do you happen to know
off the top of your head
[Music]
um i'm actually looking at it online and
i don't
see repealed language here
look at 374 colon a hyphen one it's 374
colon 22 dash l
yeah she's telling you
i think she's telling you it's a
different statue is that what the
translation was nancy
yes if uh if i could well let's just
let's look at this because to me it's
confusing here what's going on so i just
i just think that warren's looking at
can you see my screen no
no no now we can
it looks like it's still effective
some reference you're looking at that
i'm not seeing
um you know nancy let me get back to you
later on this because i'm crossing it's
just hard to do this all at once on the
screen
mary beth we need to have some answer
for
matt and chris who are going away with a
lot of stuff if this has not been
repealed nancy can you put that up one
more time
that they need to i mean they've got a
lot of things they're doing
for us time is a finite resource well
here i would just say look at 374
colon one dash lower case a
all right hang on
exceptions yep
i don't see anything about 22 in there
and i don't know that this is a repeal
either rather than just an exception
okay well
the problem i've got written in my notes
is 374 colon one
hyphen a we have that up on the screen
mary beth okay
um maybe there's something in here
that's not repealed either
it's the hyphen nance is it um
yeah so it would be this one that's the
first one you brought up nancy
374 colon 1-a okay
there's no 22 in there at all
well we can uh go back and take a look
and
okay this was the
this is the statute in question right
here that's correct
i think it may make some stuff
inapplicable but again it's just hard to
do this on the fly
okay gentlemen i appreciate your time
i appreciate you listening to our
questions i appreciate
you badgering letting us badger you a
little bit over certain things
[Music]
he's used to what he says well as you
famously said wants to be representative
and it stuck with me
you know you come from the show me state
and we're gonna have to show you you're
gonna have to
show me i hope we're able to do a little
bit of that today you were
happy to come back on tuesday we'll get
some of these questions squared away and
answered
um and if there's anything else that
comes up in writing happy to yeah i
think
um if at all possible
we need to try to square away the
amendment for us to
keep this in hb2 we need to do that
quite honestly
we expect to be done with our work on
wednesday
that's why i'm saying to you two days
knowing you're coming on tuesday
like if i tell you wednesday and then
you say no thursday i was like no sorry
too late
um and i will say that yes there's a lot
that we've covered
i don't know that there's all that much
drafting that would need to happen for
this amendment which does make me feel
that it's a reasonable
timeline so we'll certainly meet it all
right
appreciate you coming good to see you
both
um nancy and mike can
you guys uh i see george capades waiting
and i don't know who he wants to bring
with him
if you could draft bring them over tracy
is going to start and run that hearing
i'll be back in just a minute
hi commissioner this is mike hoffman we
just brought you
into the division one meeting room
mike you're welcome
i've also got uh deputy commissioner
lavers
and business administrator jill revels
with me as well
are they in the room with you or do i
need to look for them in the attendees
look for them in the attendees okay
thank you
hello rich i found you and
adding jill to the meeting now hey mike
how you doing
good haven't seen you for about a year
i know plenty of emails though right
plenty emails
so sorry to interrupt representative
emmerich we're having a little trouble
hearing you
i got to turn my mic on it's amazing how
it works when you turn your mic on
uh we will start the hearing on the
department of employment security and
we'll turn it
the floor to them for whatever they'd
like to present as it relates to their
budget
thank you so much uh representative so
i'll start just by giving a brief
overview and then
uh we then we want to talk also about
some
amendments we're putting in and then we
can take questions so the department
receives no
state general funds and the majority of
its non-matching federal funds comes
from the u.s department of labor
the biennial budget projection is based
on knowledge and expectation of the
continuation of our core programs
employment services unemployment
insurance and labor market information
the department also receives
supplemental funding in the form of
a point two percent diversion of
employees
we're having it we're having a very
difficult time hearing you i i don't
know if you've got a
mask on or uh you're not close up to the
mic but we can barely hear you
okay how's this better that's better
okay thank you sorry about that
uh the department also received
supplemental funding in the form of a
0.2
diversion of employer state unemployment
taxes for administrative support in
order
to cover federal funding shortfalls in
and from the
which the six million dollar annually is
deposited into the job training fund
the department offers a variety of
services to claimants job seekers and
employers and 12
full-service offices and two itinerary
offices located throughout the state
therefore personnel services and benefit
costs comprise the largest portion of
our overall budget
while services are currently provided
virtually we're confident we'll be able
to open our offices back in
to the public in 2021.
personnel related costs comprise
approximately 57
of our budget when unemployment claims
increases has been experienced
resulting from the pandemic nhes
receives additional federal funds based
on workloads
in excess of our base budget workload
counts
a growing economy and low unemployment
rate like new hampshire was experiencing
prior to the pandemic results in
decreased funding for
employment security to put this into
context at the start of the fy
1213 biennium the total number of staff
at the department was 453
while at the start of the fy 2021
biennium the total
number of staff was down to 249.
prior to the pandemic nhgs had the
lowest staffing levels going back at
least 40 years
considering how quickly the pandemic and
related necessary public health
restrictions impacted the state's
workforce
the department did not have time to hire
additional staff in order to meet
the growing demand for unemployment
benefits and related services
instead the department made the decision
to address this demand with existing
staff and
increasing reliance on technology
employment security staff worked
overtime equivalent to approximately 95
additional positions
in the initial months of the pandemic in
order to handle the sudden and drastic
increase in workloads employment
security staff were working longer hours
and were working seven days a week in
order to meet the demand
the employees of the department have
made incredible sacrifices during 2020
and continue to make those sacrifices
work long hours
in order to meet the needs of the
citizens of our state
understanding that such expectations
from our workforce are only realistic in
the short term we made the decision to
increase staffing levels
during the summer when workloads were
expected to decline
we've been hiring staff in the past few
months bringing in additional staff to
process claims
conduct appeals to work with customers
on the hotline
and to review claims in order to detect
fraud prior to benefits being paid
we've filled 59 vacancies since the
beginning of the pandemic and 35
positions
remain an act of recruitment many of
which are the result of internal
movement
which we have done by filling previously
funded vacant positions
we've also utilized external resources
with at first the new hampshire national
guard other state agencies whose staff
volunteered and currently an outside
vendor to support the needs around the
unemployment hotline
which was created at the outset of the
pandemic
we've received nearly a million calls
during the pandemic and have handled
this
combination of outside resources and our
own internal staff
the department of information technology
costs comprise approximately 11
of our overall budget with this budget
nhgs supports approximately 24 full-time
equivalent doit positions
19 which are embedded within nhes
the job training fund receives six
million dollars annually which
represents approximately 12 percent of
our overall budget
nhes relies heavily on technology to
administer all of our programs
but most importantly the unemployment
insurance program therefore in addition
to class
27 doit our software equipment and
equipment related
maintenance budget represents
approximately 10 percent of our overall
budget
the remaining 10 percent of our overall
budget is comprised of general operating
expenditures such as telecommunications
postage utilities
supplies rent building maintenance
contracts
the department submitted a budget of 14
810 for fy 2022 and 15 million
323 820 for fy
2023 in the category of personal
services for permanent classified and
unclassified staff
this includes 286 classified
positions of which 15 are unfunded this
biennium in
seven unclassified positions the
department also included
26 full-time temporary and 35 part-time
positions
in the fy 22-23 budget request in order
to assist with continued
elevated workloads for which above-based
funding is anticipated
the unemployment crime trust fund is
currently at 112 million dollars as of
march 2nd 2021 this current balance
includes the additional 50 million
which was recently deposited to the
trust fund from the state's
cares acts flex funds to put this in
perspective the balance was
approximately
300 million prior to the pandemic nhes
has paid out approximately 304 million
in state ui benefits during the pandemic
as nhes administers both state and
federal
unemployment programs we've paid out
approximately 1.7 billion dollars
in total benefits the majority of which
was through federally funded
supplemental assistance programs
based upon our current trust fund
forecasts and the initial 50 million
dollars
of infusion from the cares x flex funds
we currently anticipate the trust fund
will remain solvent during calendar year
2021.
while this is great news for new
hampshire there are many assumptions
involved in this forecast that could
shift suddenly
because of the pandemic we need to be
cautious with the forecasting of the
trust fund during these unprecedented
times
and certainly need to refrain from
making long-term projections
without benefit of caveats and and
proper
analysts analysis of all risks
there are currently 23 states that are
borrowing from the us treasury in order
to pay benefits including massachusetts
and connecticut here in new england we
are not borrowing
nor have we borrowed uh regarding the
proposals in house bill 2 involving the
department the first such proposal is
section
130 through 132 which involves changes
to the section in state law
that adjust employer tax rates in order
to maintain the solvency of the
unemployment cost trust fund currently
the manner which
revenue is generated into the trust fund
we ask
the least of employers when they can
most afford it
like during periods of economic growth
and low unemployment
and the most of employers when they can
least afford it like during an economic
downturn
endemic or recession this series of
amendments seeks to reverse this
upside down dynamic first by eliminating
the tax surcharges that drive up
employer tax rates during times when
they can least afford it
like during the great recession or
currently during the pandemic
these surcharges are only needed because
the solvency controls allowing the trust
fund to grow
to the predetermined point of solvency
are set too low
if the trust fund thresholds are
increased then the surcharges that hit
employers during economic downturns and
no longer necessary
second these amendments increase the
second and third of the trust fund
solvency thresholds ultimately allowing
the fund to grow to 400 million dollars
rather than the current limit of 300
million dollars before employers receive
the maximum reduction to their
unemployment tax rate
we're confident that if these changes
had been implemented prior to the great
recession new hampshire would have
not needed to borrow the 120 million
that we had borrowed from the federal
treasury in order to pay benefits
and if implemented prior to the pandemic
we would have been able to avoid the
trust fund needing
50 million dollars from the cares flex
act funds the first threshold would
remain unchanged
providing tax relief when the fund grows
to 250 million dollars
the second threshold would be increased
from 275 million
to 350 million and the third threshold
would be increased from 300 million
to 400 million by setting these top
top two thresholds at a higher trust
fund balance
then we eliminate the need to implement
surcharges when the trust fund falls
because we will have allowed the fund to
grow to a sufficient level
to achieve solvency the second proposal
contained in house bill 2 involving the
department is found in sections
69 through 74 creating the granite state
paid family leave plan commission could
you suspend a moment
sure thank you so the first section
which you just
told us about thank you for doing that
is on page 60 guys
and it's 1 30.
and 131 132 as the commissioner said
commissioners i understand your
testimony you are in favor of those and
we need those
is that correct correct could i have a
motion
to approve those sections representative
emerick moves to approve
section 130 through 132
representative griffin seconds is there
any discussion on the motion
see none with the clerk please call the
roll if you're in favor of approving
sections 130 to 132 when your name is
called please say aye
if you are opposed please say nay okay
madam chairman
yes vice chairman yes the clerk votes
yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman is excused
representative hatch yes represent walls
yes okay the motion passes six to
nothing
okay thank you commissioner tell us
again what section we're now going to
that you're going to talk about
thank you madam chairman and committee
members so now the second section
uh section 69-74
creating the granite state paid family
leave plan
okay the governor is going to come in
and talk to us
about that as well so we won't be voting
on that today sir but please tell
us about it okay the department
involvement in this proposal is with
administering two
new revenue funds the first is the fm li
premium fund and the second is the fmli
premium
stabilization trust fund in both
instances the department would utilize
the option
contained in the proposal to contract
with private sector benefit
administrators in order to carry out
these functions
the reason why the department feels
contracting this out to be competitively
bid in
the private insurance administrator
market is that these types of services
are currently available
and carried out by private sector
providers so it would make little sense
for the state
to take the time which has been
estimated to be at least 24 months
and invest the people and the money to
create the necessary i.t
infrastructure to account for and
operate operationalize these funds
instead the department would utilize the
language contained in this proposal to
competitively procure
these services from a private
third-party benefit administrator
we would expect this process to take
approximately six months from passage of
the program
until entering into a contract with the
chosen vendor
and with that i close our remarks we'll
obviously look forward to continue
the great work that we're doing here at
employment security
with our employers job seekers and
providing the assistance necessary
to our citizens in order to get by
during this
pandemic situation that we've incurred
commissioner thank you and i would like
to
say to you that you guys did a lot of
work for us
under very difficult circumstances
really stood up for the
people in our state when things were not
going well
and i would like to offer my sincere
thanks to you and your entire
staff thank you so much madam chairman
representative hatch are you are you
waving to me or is your hand
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry man i'm tearing
but you can wave at me it's the most
entertainment i've had for quite a while
well with pleasure as well um
i'm i'm sorry for this first i i did
know your remarks about i'm sure but
secondly
if if you could commissioner in one
sentence
um talk about your recommendation for
the
family leave plan um i could barely hear
most of what you said but i i certainly
didn't want to interrupt you and i don't
need to hear it all again
could you do that or is that not
practical yeah um
actually deputy commissioner layers is
on as well and he has been heavily
involved in that so i'll let him
address that and maybe you'll hear him a
little clearer than me
and my scratchy voice well thank you
commissioner and i apologize for having
to ask
no no no no representatives good
afternoon everyone this is rich lavers
so
um representative hatch to to talk uh to
oh i think i absent
accidentally muted him
rich rich you're talking and it's my
fault that nobody can hear you
oh i'm back you're back i apologize it's
late in the afternoon
all right uh well i'm glad to be back i
got booted out of there for a second
yeah i
i'm sorry i was trying to promote you so
we could see your picture as well and
instead i disconnected you bingo
all right so the the the paid family
leave proposal that the the governor put
forward in house bill 2
the the involvement from employment
security
is minimal compared to the role that the
department of administrative services
will play
and admin services would his envision to
oversee
the procurement of
private sector insurance providers to to
provide the benefit the state employees
and then
private and private companies could then
opt in
um and then provide the coverage to
their employees and then there would
also be a pooled risk program
for those individual employees that are
at an employer that
elected not to participate in the
program so our role
is secondary to admin services and our
role would be in
administering the two revenue programs
to new revenue funds that were created
and so there's language contained in
both of those sections that allows the
department
to procure the administration of
those funds to an outside provider
we've been talking with many folks
throughout the
several years that we've been talking
about paid family leave
that type of service is already being
administered in the private market
with plans that are in place third-party
benefit administrators are doing that
type of work
and so the department felt that it made
little sense
to spend the time money and to create a
new unit within the department
um when we could competitively procure
that out
and seek that from an existing
administrator who probably
oh not probably definitely already has
the i.t programming
already created obviously we have
we'd be able to compare any proposals
that we get
against our projected costs of creating
it in-house in the state
we want to make sure that going that
route would
produce efficiencies not only in
creating a new program but in dollars
spent
so that would be something we would be
reviewing and comparing against but that
would be the goal
would be to competitively procure that
service from an existing
uh third-party administrator
representative hatch you have follow-up
no that's that's fine thank you
i just couldn't hear the commissioner
and i just wanted to uh understand what
he said no that's okay
i'm sorry i disconnected mr lavers in
the middle while i was trying to make
his picture come up as well
thank you rich and madam chair one other
um
we had um uh submitted an amendment
uh our proposal to be considered for
amending into house bill 2
regarding the uh state being able to
participate
in the integrity data hub and i know
that's something that
you had wanted to discuss as well yes
and i
mike do i have that amendment back i
know i emailed it over to you
i will look at my stack real quickly but
if not i can share the screen
[Music]
747 747
and if you could share your screen so
the people at home can have it
i thought you had brought that up to me
at lunchtime
okay it's up on the screen and rich
those of us sitting in
lob have a copy as well because mr
hoffman very efficiently provided it at
lunch
so please talk about it all right so the
the section that uh would be amended
here
is 282 118 this is the the provision in
the unemployment compensation statute
that deals with confidentiality of
unemployment comp information
so this language would allow
the department to participate in what is
called the integrity data hub
the integrity data hub it's a nationally
coordinated anti-fraud prevention
strategy it's particularly focused on
id theft fraud which has been a major
problem
for every state during the pandemic and
their unemployment
programs have just been getting
inundated with id
theft claims we've had about 20 000 of
these in new hampshire
um and that the the goal is that these
fraud schemes as their
um targeted against one state
that we know that those are not isolated
incidents
and that the experiences of one state
and the successes that they have in
preventing this type of activity
detecting it and then shutting it down
that the best strategy
is to share those experiences across all
states
so that we have the the benefit of those
other states that have been able to
deter this fraud we can prevent it here
in new hampshire and
protect our trust fund this would be
administered by the national association
of state workforce
agencies it's a trade group that every
state workforce agency belongs
it is being implemented in partnership
and now in naswa the national
association of state workforce agencies
is the agent of the u.s department of
labor
so it is very much being promoted
and overseen by the federal government
we would retain ownership of our
unemployment compensation information so
our benefit information that would be
provided we would retain
ownership of that other states are not
allowed to search
our data it's only done by uh
the naswa who's overseeing this in their
integrity team
who would search our claims data to
detect
fraud schemes that they have found in
other states
they would then alert us to these
schemes and then allow us to shut down
those claims
we would be able to terminate the gr the
agreement
with 30 days notice and all
but three states at this point
have indicated their likelihood
of participating and we feel that
the language here provides sufficient
controls
so that if the department were
uncomfortable
felt that this program was not being
properly administered
or put the state's information at risk
we would be able to terminate that
agreement immediately
but with the the amount of
id theft that is taking place
trying to do this on our own and trying
to stay ahead
of what is a very coordinated
sophisticated
multinational attack against the
unemployment compensation systems
of this country we can't continue to do
this by ourself
we want to be proactive we want to stay
ahead of the fraud instead of reacting
to it
and we think this is the best course of
action for
new hampshire and going forward and with
that
i'll stop and can take any questions
that madam chair you might have or other
members of
thank you representative hatch you have
your hand up
sorry my mistake okay it doesn't look
like
we have any questions represent walls
has raised her hand represent walls
i do i have a couple of questions one is
there any charge to the state does it
cost the state anything to participate
in this
there's no cost to the states we uh new
hampshire along with all of the other
states and territories
we are dues paying members in the
national association of state workforce
agencies
um the the cost of creating the data hub
are being
paid for by those dues together with u.s
department of labor so right now there's
no additional cost for states to
participate
thank you and i just want to clarify you
said that the state has 20
000 cases of id theft that in the last
year
that's a frightening and very large
number i just wanted to confirm i heard
it correctly
um it's an incredibly scary number um
representative
we've had uh 20 000 of these cases and
the men and women that we have here that
are responsible for
literally reviewing every single new
claim as it gets filed to make sure that
it's not
a fraudulent claim they deserve all of
the credit
for the fact that new hampshire has
prevented payment in over
99 of these id theft cases
you know the credit doesn't go uh to me
it doesn't go to leadership it goes to
these folks that have just been doing
incredible work day in and day out
but we know it's not sustainable um what
they're currently doing
and we need to have a better strategy
which involves
um as like everything else um involves
technology
and and coordinating with other states
so that's where idh really comes in and
will benefit us
thank you representative emmerich moves
the adoption of amendment 202107478
representative griffin's seconds if you
are in favor of
the adoption of amendment 2021-0747h
when your name is called please say yes
if you are not please say no
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative lishman is excused
representative hatch yes 20 000 times
okay representative walls yes another 20
000.
thank you okay it passes six to nothing
that is
a past the governor's
the the employment budget has zero
general fund dollars so i would like to
approve that
as well and thank them for their
presentation representative emerick do
you move approval
representative griffin to you second if
you're in favor of approving the
employment security department budget
when your name is called please say yes
if you're not
please say no yes i actually have some
questions
here because i'm getting complaints
about some of the appeals having to do
and some of the issues having to do with
employment overcharges
that had nothing to do with the
climates and there's been these huge
things and there's a couple of things
that have come up
one as i'm seeing in my ncsl and other
notices
that there are states like missouri that
are introducing legislation to forgive
the federal portion of that overpayment
and i'm wondering what the status of
that is here can we forgive the federal
or the state portion when the claimant
it's undue hardship on the claimant and
they have had no
through no fault of their own they
receive the overpayment and secondly
under federal law those appeals are
supposed to occur within
okay one question at a time
not a book a load of questions all right
so
the question seems to be other states
are
filing a bill has anybody filed a bill
to do that
here uh madam chair this is
rich slavers i'll take i'll take that
first question right so the
ability to forgive federal overpayments
is governed by federal law
it's what they refer to as their equity
and good conscience standard
test so a state must implement their
tests
unless they've enacted their own law
that is considered consistent and
compliant with the federal test
seems unnecessary since we can just
simply borrow
and use the federal test new hampshire
has already started to forgive some of
those debts
and what it requires is us to look at
two things
one we have to first determine whether
the individual is
at fault in creating the overpayment and
if not at fault
then we look at whether or not repayment
would create a financial hardship
so we've we implemented a process uh
approximately two months ago for
individuals to start
applying for waivers if they had a
federal overpayment
all of that information is on our
website we have received approximately 2
requests from individuals to have their
overpayment waived
so we have been processing those
initially we were waiting for
guidance from u.s department of labor on
implementation
of that standard which we now have with
regard to state
overpayments if it were in the state
trust fund dollars
a current state statute allows those to
be
forgiven and restitution not required if
the individual is not
at fault so similar to the federal
standard so we have been doing that
right along
what we have found although the
department does screw up occasionally we
do make mistakes
just like everybody else and there are
occasions
certainly with the volume that we've
seen and with all of these new programs
that all have their own
brand new eligibility criteria there are
times
when uh an overpayment or improper
payment
that results is the the fault of the
department
those individuals will all be forgiven
and not be required to be repaid
however a lot of the overpayments that
we are dealing with
are don't fit into that bucket a lot of
these are with individuals
particularly self-employed or those that
didn't have their wages previously
reported to the department
overstated their earnings and they did
that in
an effort to increase their weekly
benefit amount
and they self-attested to those
overstated earnings
and then when they provided their their
federal finance
federal income tax records that are
required to substantiate their ben
their benefit amount those earnings were
much lower
those people have since been found
overpaid they will be
at fault they will be required to repay
those i know they're not happy about
that
but in those instances it's clearly the
fault of the individual
we also have other situations where
individuals
this and this happens a lot more than
one would expect
individuals that applied for benefits at
the outset of the pandemic
who had actually uh quit employment for
personal reasons
prior to the pandemic a lot of people
who had left employment
in the fourth quarter of 2019 or in
january and february of 2020
who then file for benefits tell us that
they left employment for a coronavirus
related reason
we pay them benefits we then later learn
from their employer
no no no they had left employment back
in january
to for personal reasons those people are
found overpaid
those people should not be forgiven
either because they misrepresented the
circumstances of their
their separation and were not eligible
for benefits
so we have to parse through those issues
we have to determine whether or not
someone is
at fault uh we try to do that as
expeditiously
as possible for those that are appealing
those determinations
we have hired two additional rounds of
appeal tribunal chairpersons
um with uh three people in the in the
in the prior round uh three people
starting tomorrow
to increase our ability to process those
appeals as quickly as possible
we also will be issuing an rfp out to
private sector law firms
and uh allowing them uh to conduct some
of these hearings so that we can
expedite those appeals
as well um so it it's the appeals are
our difficult subject in order to handle
quickly
i think we're doing our best with
increasing our own staffing
but also leverage leveraging outside
private sector
attorneys that have experience in
employment law
follow up represent walls indeed so a
couple of things first of all i want to
say
i think you have done a yeoman's job and
i don't want you
because this is any way a personal
attack on you uh commissioners
i'm so awed by what you've done having
said that
i'm hearing from constituents that it's
that they
on the appeals that it's taking six
months for an appeal to be scheduled
yet the federal requirement is that you
have to do
60 within 30 days and 80 within 45 days
and right now you're just starting to
schedule people who made their appeal
in october and i'm not sure what the
implication of that is is being so far
out of compliance with the federal
standards
okay representative walls i appreciate
that mr lavers
could you get representative walls's
phone number these are obviously not
budget questions but they are legitimate
questions and give her a call
later when we are done with the budget
hearing i've got one more budget
or one more money related question well
you haven't asked any money related
questions yet as far as the budget goes
so
if you do have something related to the
budget i appreciate your helping your
constituents i want to get you that help
but not right now during a budget
hearing so do you have a budget question
well it has to do with the interest on
the overpayments i'm not sure if that
qualifies his budget but they're
collecting
interest on the overpayments that
they've forgiven and i'm concerned about
that
i don't think that's in the budget
either you're going to take that up with
mr labors
thank you would you like her to
read off her phone number mr labors
or would you rather look it up because
this is open to the public i don't want
to
open representative walls to identity
theft either
commissioner lavers has my contact
information we've been in touch on
constituent issues previously thank you
madam chair
okay okay good thank you i don't want to
have
be the cause of id theft
all right so we have a motion on the
floor to approve the employment budget
if you're in favor when your name is
called please say yes
if you're opposed please say no mr clerk
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative
leishman is excused representative hatch
yes
representative walsh yes thank you
pass the six nothing unit okay
commissioner and this deputy
commissioner i think we have
covered all your items i thank you for
spending the time with us this afternoon
it's always nice to hear from you and
please keep up the good work
thank you thank you madam chairman and
committee members
mike can you bring up
amendment 2021-0767 please
6-7 this will complete
something we started yesterday this is
the deletion
of the three doj sections in hb2
151 154
155 and 156 we
had a written letter
from the agency asking us to delete
these sections it should be too cool
representative emmerich moves to
approve amendment 2021
0767h and representative griffin
seconds the motion is there any
discussion
on this deletion
see none
if you're in favor when your name is
called please say yes if you're opposed
please say no
chairman yes vice chairman yes
clerk folks yes representative griffin
yes representation of the excuse
representative hatch
yes purpose of walls
mary beth sorry i muted again yes
okay it passes six nothing thank you
good good for you
mike will you bring up two zero two one
oh seven one one this
is from our friends in the judicial
branch this is
section 16 which this morning
they asked us to delete so that their
budget
would work and we have the
deletion
yeah representative would like five
minutes to read this amendment but he is
going to move the adoption of amendment
2021-07118
and represent griffin seconds it is
there any
discussion
see none if you are in favor of the
adoption when your name is called please
say yay
if you are opposed please say nay okay
madam chairman yes uh vice chairman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes
leishman is excused representative hatch
bill yes uh representative walsh
yes okay six nothing it's unanimous
madam chairman
okay i'm going to ask you to turn to
section 142
in hb2 and i'm going to ask
mr hoffman to bring up amendment
20210798h
this is the amendment i talked about
this morning
random chair what page i don't know
okay can you give me the section number
again please
it is 142. thank you
62 page 62. represent griffin found it
thank you
i'm still looking seven nine eight h no
that's not the right one
seven this is the the um
dnc one mike 0798
h
it is on six it starts at the bottom of
64. really what we're working with is on
page 65.
so i talked to you this morning they had
five projects in there all using
general sum fund dollars some of them
will raise
revenue that will go into the parks fund
this amendment approves
the redevelopment and improvement
projects at jericho mountain beach
area campground including rv dump
station
two new pit toilets ten campsites four
new camping cabins
and the extension of water utilities to
the beach area
it also approves the sum of
thousand 347.000 for the purpose of the
electrical upgrade projects at the
hampton rv
park where we heard from the agency that
they could not
have rvs plug in anymore because of the
outmoded
stuff it does eliminate the other three
projects which also
equal another million dollars not
because they aren't good but because we
just don't have
enough money to do it all and i kind of
question why
the fort stark project doubled in cost
and we didn't get a good answer
so that's what this amendment does it is
up on the screen
everybody can see that questions on the
amendment
represent emmerich moves to approve
2021.07
you represent griffin's seconds any
discussion on the motion
scene none if you're in favor of the
approval of amendment 2021-0798-h
when your name is called please say aye
if you're opposed please say nay
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk both ts
representative griffin yes
representative leachman is excused
representative hatch
yes represent walls yes oh it passes six
nothing unanimous
all right guys i've got one more more
amendment for it today
and this one what have i done with it
well i thought it did
maybe i've lost it
well hang on while i dig through the
papers
okay i'm i'm doing this so
representative burge can't get caught up
well i got it out i don't know what they
did with it
fascinating
maybe i don't have an amendment
i know it's here
too much paperwork not enough hands to
keep track of all of it
all right i can't find it so that's all
right
we're not going to do it do we have
mr hoffman and nancy do we have any
other
department budgets we have heard that we
could oh i guess we could approve the
executive department
we looked briefly at the executive
department
which is the governor's budget it was
either below funding
or that 27th pay period slightly above
do i have a motion to approve the
executive department budget
representative moves representative
griffin seconds so on the motion to
approve the executive department budget
if you're in favor when your name is
called say aye if you're opposed say nay
madam chairman aye vice chairman
aye the clerk votes yes representative
griffin
representative leachman is excused
representative hatch yes
represent walls yes unanimous six
nothing madam chairman
mike and nancy i think we had well
i'm sorry but i'm going to go ahead and
approve the corrections budget and i
know where we stand with
the fact we wanted more transitional
housing but it is what it is
so do i have a motion to approve the
corrections budget as amended
madam chairman i'm wondering if you can
wait till next tuesday to do that and
just give me some time to poke around
and do what if i can find some money for
at least some of the transitional
housing
and what will you cut because it's not
just moving money in it's cutting
something else
well that's exactly what i'm asking time
to find is what what if anything is
appropriate to cut
okay you're gonna have till next tuesday
thank you you're welcome
i don't mike i don't see any other
budgets that we can approve right now
uh i nothing comes to mind at this point
i have three or four uh amendments over
here i can bring them over
today or i can hold them until tuesday
why don't you bring them over and then
i'll talk to them about the amendment i
have lost in my paperwork that you gave
us and maybe it will
show up and i'll feel better okay be
over in a few minutes
uh no on monday
monday on tuesday
we had house bill 591
which had passed the house came to
finance as a second committee
we voted to suspend it i'm sorry to
retain it
to see if we could put it into the
budget
and i know the amendment's here so i'm
going to dig around for a minute
that basically gives 36
thirty six thousand five hundred and
forty dollars in 22 and the same amount
23 and it is what
vice chairman of ways and means patrick
abrami described to me
as a mistake ways and means made last
biennium
and they wanted to correct it
it is revenue we are entitled to it
if i can find that amendment that is the
piece i have if not i'm going to have
mike
make more copies for us and we'll have
it next tuesday
but i wanted to let you know what i was
looking for i mean we had looked at that
on tuesday together
so it's not a surprise if we could we
were going to put it back in here
and i'm sure can you please give me the
bill number again 591.
thank you very much you're welcome
i picked it up when i picked up the
other one by mistake
oh okay
i just have to get mike to give me more
here somewhere
yes
i was so tired
to correct myself
apparently
mary beth and bill this is going to
reference page
370 in the governor's budget please
mary beth and bill have you found paige
yeah all right the motion is going to be
as we discussed earlier when
the budget the governor's budget
director was here
to remove the footnote i.e
organizational note
to delete the organizational note in the
middle of the page
which says in the event the expenditures
in either fiscal year in this accounting
unit are greater than application fees
and other filing fees
the site evaluation committee may
request
with prior approval with prior approval
additional funding because that's not
been happening they've been
asking after they spent the money so the
motion made by representative emerick
seconded by representative griffin is to
delete the organizational footnote on
page
370.
see no discussion when the clerk is
ready if you're in favor of deleting
this organizational footnote on page 370
when your name is called you will say
yay if you are opposed
you will say no
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman is excused
representative hatch
yes represent walls yes okay the motion
pass is six nothing
madam chairman
i'm not sure if that was mike or not it
was a mic
okay i have micah you there yet
just got back perfect bring up the doj
amendment if you will the
this is an hb1
amendment
we have a page number
and mike is going to bring the amendment
up on the screen so you can see it
we are going to make a small
cut however what we're doing is we are
delaying
the start of the director of diversity
and community outreach
the position is still approved it will
be funded with the new start date
but in order to meet our what we have to
cut per ways and means
house ways and means vote this will
delay
the start and it saves us a hundred and
eleven thousand dollars
madam chair delayed to start from when
to win
until january 1st 2023 i think that's on
the screen you can see it
so it's delaying it by six months it's
delaying it until january 1st 2023 which
is 18 months
yeah sorry it's just small okay thank
you
and again i'm hoping the senate when
they get the business taxes
can actually fix this but in the
meantime we're trying to
represent walls is now trying to get in
more transitional housing and
this you can't count this cut mary beth
i'm sorry it's one i needed in order to
make what we had to do so
no no no i'm sorry about that
representative emmerich moves house
hb1 amendment to doj page 272
representative griffin
seconds the motion if you're in favor of
the motion
when your name is called please say yay
if you're opposed please say nay
and the clerk when you're ready may call
the roll madam chairman
yes vice chairman yes the clerk both yes
representative griffin
representative leitchman excuse
representative hatch yes
represent walls no okay the motion pass
is six nothing man
sherman oh representative i voted no
i'm sorry i take that back madam
chairman
and fastest five to one thank you sorry
mary bats
that's okay mostly i vote yes just not
on this one
some of them are hard well some of them
you got to let your position knowing i
knew i was going to lose
all right i have an hb1 amendment
and an hb 2 amendment that go together
mike if you can bring up the parole
board hb1
amendment we will do
that piece first
okay in hb2
the governor proposes
eliminating four members of the parole
board and moving them
till what section please
in hp2 i don't know we're looking at hb1
right now
so we reviewed those sections earlier
that's okay what page
5.5 page 525.
thank you um
he proposed a salary in addition he
changed
the number of days they were going to
work until 36 days
in a fiscal year and he proposed the
salary to be thirty thousand dollars
per member for 36 days salary
this hb1 amendment
changes the proposed annual pay for the
five board members
from thirty thousand to twenty thousand
it also he also proposed
moving the chairman of the board into a
full-time
unclassified position right now the
chairman is just
a board member and will continue to be a
board member
this amendment further delays the start
of the unclassified chairman
by six months that chairman will still
be a board member
she's a board member now she will
continue to be a board member
and this change which again
unfortunately represent walls is not
going to be able to capture for
transitional housing amounts to a
savings of
a hundred and a hundred thousand a
hundred thousand seven hundred and
eighty three dollars
in fiscal year 22
and a small savings in fiscal year 23
because the salary will be 20 000 not
30 000 in each of the two years but the
chairman will
after the first six months be the
full-time
unclassified parole board member
representative emerick moves to approve
hp1 amendment to page 525 represent
griffin
seconds if you're in favor of the motion
you will say yes when your name is
called if you are not
you will say no madam chairman
yes vice chairman yes the clerk votes
yes representative griffin
yes representative is excused
representative hatch
yes mary beth sorry representative walsh
sorry
i'm representing walls okay thank you
yeah the motion passes six nothing out
of turn
okay robert i get called so many wrong
names if you put mary in front of
almost anything i answer to it i have
the same
i have the same problem or well they
call me siebers
the berg i mean uh t-berger tea bags you
name it
amongst other things okay bill i knew
you'd chime in
thank you most often these days i get
called mary jane and i'm sure you guys
can all figure out why
yeah i don't want to do that right now
all right mike also brought me
what is section 292 and hb2
section 290. this goes along with what
we did in hb1
for doj yes it changes the effective
date
for house bill 2 sections 157 to 158
okay can you bring that up on the screen
yes thank you
i must have given him one too many again
yeah so this amends section 292 by
replacing it
with the effective date for what we just
voted in for
for the hb1 amendment
no um we did doj first
representative emerick moves to approve
20 21 07
998 representative griffin seconds
if you're in favor of this motion when
your name is called you will say yes if
you're opposed you will say no
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes representative griffin
yes
representative liesman is excused
representative hatch
sorry yes okay represent
false yes okay the unanimous six nothing
madam chairman
okay i have a letter from ken maryfield
that is dated march 11th which is today
which mike hoffman just brought up
and references
section 129 in hb
2 which is his section that we still had
open
hmm
mike can you bring his letter up on the
screen
yes i'm uh i'm looking for it
in fact i'm having trouble finding the
letter i just got today
uh-huh i'm not the only one losing
things that makes me feel better
now i can find it in his email
and open it there so in hb2 we're on
page 157 we barely
oh 57 we've barely managed to get
ourselves there while
mike is looking for the letter so we're
having our own
problems
what section madam chair oh 129 i'm
sorry i think it's actually 128 he's
used the wrong
okay thank you
got it
is that legible uh yeah i was legible
enough this
is this is about the apprenticeship
council we did actually approve this
earlier in the day
and you wanted i think mary beth did you
ask or
bill i can't remember what is this in in
line with
the federal program
and so we just got this and basically
mike hoffman can email you a copy later
but he um
he says that we were because the current
concerns the division expressed
the change changes about the changes
shown
the effort associated with
apprenticeship that you see in hb2
is simply our attempt to square state
law
with the reality of federal control over
registered apprenticeship
in new hampshire since 2007
the state apprenticeship council has had
no role
in the approval or recommendation of
registered apprenticeships
the council is simply advisory and
supportive
a letter from the u.s department of
labor dated august 6 2007
states in relevant part quote oa the
federal office of
office of apprenticeship will assume
full responsibility and authority
over registered apprenticeship in new
hampshire end quote
and a responsive letter from the
department of the usdol
dated august 14 2017 states in relative
relative relevant part quote we are in
agreement that the effect of this
legislative change is that the state
relinquishes the authority to register
apprenticeship programs
end quote so he's
clarifying for us we have approved that
section
yes we did we did approve earlier uh
but then we wanted to have a check to
see
if it really was the federal law
madam chairman my recollection is is we
did not approve it because we were
waiting for this letter i'm happy to
approve it but
i pray we can vote it again it's late i
don't care i have down that we approved
it
representative ember says he is happy to
move section 129.
okay represent uh hatch
seconds and on the approval of 129 if
you're in favor please say yes if you're
opposed please say no
and i promise you mr clerk this is the
last vote of the day
for your tired fingers
all right madam chairman yes uh
vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin
representative leishman is excused
representative hatch yes
representative walsh yes my ocean pass
is six nothing madam chairman
all righty guys we are adjourned until
tuesday morning at nine o'clock
have a wonderful weekend thank you for
all of your hard work and
madam chair i'm sorry if i may just i
want to just
personally thank you for your patience
and just let you know that a great lunch
that could be mealed
is beef eaters london that's all yeah i
hate to tell you but you have to be here
to get your lunch
thank you for the offer of letting me
email you something or mail you
something
have a great weekend thank you